[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yo what's going on everybody oh my
goodness what a stream we have today
it's it's been it's been craziness the
whole week Jan and I have been prepping
for this moment there's been highs
there's been lows but you know what we
got it figured out mostly and we're able
to do this stream out of
miraculous
miraculously able to do this stream
we're gonna here's what we're gonna do
I'm gonna give you a quick overview
we're gonna hop into it right
so first off welcome everybody thank you
for joining me live
this is going to be an incredible time
over the next few hours here so
AI art we've all heard about it maybe
we've messed with it some of you more
than others but what we're going to do
on this stream
um Jan is about as far out as it goes
when it comes to diving into the
technology
um I've only messed with mid-journey
right maybe a lot of you guys have
messed with mid-journing yourselves
we're gonna guide you through the whole
process from basic to Advanced Master
Advanced like pull your hair out
Advanced
um
it's going to be a blast the whole way
through I promise we'll start in
mid-journey we're going to go over
prompts what makes a good prom what
makes a bad prompt blender Guru
literally just put out a video like two
days ago on how you can bring your
likeness into mid-journey
um so I'll show you that as well I've
got a link to you know we gotta link to
all the resources there's so many
resources in the description
um once we get through mid-journey and
we talk about prompts we're gonna go to
a program called stable diffusion and
I'm going to show you how cool it is you
can you can upload your your likeness
into stable diffusion and create any
version of yourself you guys saw it in
the uh the starting screen and the
countdown that was myself that was Jan
all made from from stable diffusion
using dream Booth so
we're gonna get into that whole workflow
we're gonna show it off it's going to be
craziness
um so we got we got some people coming
in here we got 247 people what's good
what's good uh welcome everybody uh I
hope you all are ready to learn I hope
you guys are ready to laugh and have a
good time because
it's this is gonna be awesome
um the whole week we've been preparing
for this moment trying to get the
programs working all this and that so
we're gonna do our best to get you guys
up and running I know it's confusing
but
you know that's what we're here for um
Jan Jan set me up uh Nico was even with
us last night helping us so shout outs
to Nico from Corridor
um yeah it's freaking awesome freaking
awesome so
before we hop in
you know you know we got gotta gotta pay
the bills right so we're gonna talk
about a sponsor today we're gonna plant
some trees today
very good things all good things so I'll
see you guys in just a minute
keep your butts in the seat
let's plant some trees
all right let's get real for a minute I
try to keep these Brands as valuable and
genuine as possible for both myself and
you guys granted this one's a little
different but I do think it's the most
important one we've talked about yet
today's stream is sponsored by
established titles a company that plants
a tree with every order and works with
global Charities like one tree planted
and trees for the future to support
Global reforestation efforts in the
Scottish Countryside and other parts of
the globe established titles makes it
fun too so on top of planning a tree or
three they're leaning into historic
Scottish land owner custom and sending
you this personalized certificate which
is proof granting you use of the prefix
Lord or lady on any document allowing
for prefixes look I'm all down to plant
some trees so I threw a hundred bucks
down for me and my good buddy Jan for a
nice 10 square foot lot they're running
an absurd early Black Friday deal for up
to 80 off and if you use the code
Punisher at checkout you'll get yourself
an extra 10 so go to established
titles.com Punisher Linked In the
description below in the first 200 Lords
and Ladies to grab a plot will all be
within walking distance of each other so
we can build the Punisher Kingdom
together and be plot Buds and hang as
Shady big stumped ant looking trees just
blasting oxygen from our sappy pores
until the end of time
Jan Lozada how does it feel to be
immortalized as a tree in a 10-foot
Square plot
I mean it's great I've I've always
wanted to live forever
and you know now I feel like uh for
hundreds of years out before us there's
going to be two two trees riding one
wheels and and and making uh January AI
generated art just living living a good
life and then maybe we get cut down and
build a house and we get to live
together as like a different form of us
right we could be turned into books you
know maybe but you know that's that's
that's not the point that's not the
point while we got you here today Jen I
am so excited to do this we Jan Jan dude
we have been my life has been in your
hands uh more times than anyone else
times a thousand
um true true true uh we do a lot of rock
climbing
um and multi-pitch big walls so quite
literally oftentimes we will be a couple
hundred feet off the ground uh uh
tethered into each other making sure
that as much fun as we're having we're
also being safe absolutely we also very
recently went into a cave and became
cave boys which is uh that was pretty
sweet
and a tough responsibility I don't think
I've ever I don't think I'm the same now
yeah like literally we hooked up we we
set up an anchor around some rocks and
rappelled down into the depths of a cave
that was crazy
um you know we cook on our on our
missions too we play Smash Bros our
missions Jan has been a long time friend
you guys know Jan you know if you watch
Corridor at all you know Jan
um it's an honor to have you here this
is so cool that we're do we're finally
doing a stream together we've been
talking about this forever and like on
my rock climbing on our rock climbing
Adventures you have been blasting the
good word of AI art into my ear for the
longest time and like At first I was
like I don't know about AI art I don't
know how I feel about it I'm a little
scared about it I'm sure a lot of you
guys watching here feel the same but Jan
you were the first person for me to be
like no this is the best I'm going as
far as possible and I'm so glad you did
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I uh you know
uh uh uh as a cinematographer which I
did and have done for a number of uh
number of years we've had that we've
we've worked a bunch of projects
together you found movies as a full-on
feature films
and as a person who spends a lot of time
trying to get a camera to places
that are often it's very hard to get a
camera to move smoothly across you know
a lake
um uh it takes a lot of Technology right
uh so what if you could do that
with a sentence and you know a a a lot
of zeros and ones and math and then you
get the same results right now we're not
there yet we're not at the point where I
can just movie Enter but uh you know
almost two years ago I was on a
one-wheel ride with our good friend
who's already been shouted out I'll
shout them out again Nico peeringer
shout outs dude uh we were riding one
Wheels on the side of mountain in the
middle of the night I mean that uh it
actually happens often but he brought up
uh some AI generated images and this was
two years ago so it was the equivalent
of you know uh gaussian noise with the
stick figure in there there really
wasn't much detail or really anything to
write home about
but if I I mean I couldn't get over the
the idea that you can just type words
hit enter and then a rough amalgamation
of what you said would generate back to
you like to me that was we found magic
right that is uh uh because it doesn't
take long for you to think well where is
this technology going to be in a year
where is this technology going to be in
two years and suddenly you've heard
extrapolate and before you know
this is a big deal we should probably
all be paying attention to this uh this
is going to be a game changer and lo and
behold you know uh about three four
months ago I think I think when um uh
God he used to be a Daily Show
correspondent what's his name um
uh he was on HBO John Oliver John Oliver
who I'm picking up when John Oliver did
a you know whole half hour on
mid-journey uh we we've officially come
into pop culture right like we're we're
there and uh and it's funny because if
you go back and look at
um uh uh you know three months ago when
he put out
um an episode on this the art looks so
old in the AI art community like we've
Advanced so far in three months that I
look back and just like think fondly oh
the beta days oh that's crazy how fast
all this stuff updates like literally
literally last night like we were trying
to get all this stuff working and you
know flowing correctly and there's like
new updates of all the stuff and now it
suddenly doesn't work anymore it's
because it's like being updated as we're
trying to figure it out and it's it's
absurd I think what we should do right
now let's let's show everybody here like
where we're at right now but you want to
hop into dream Booth let's do a couple
versions of each other to kind of show
where the stream will get to and then
we're gonna kind of take it back and hop
into mid-journey and start from the
beginning and we'll work all the way up
to what we're going to show you right
now so let's switch over real quick
oh so just a good a good note for
everyone out there this is all still
very experimental like if if you don't
like digging into code
wait a few months and they'll they'll be
some banging app that's out and you know
you can just use that but if you are
here chances are you you like doing the
dirty work so yeah so I have um I got
your model pulled up I'm gonna show you
guys how to do this
um towards the end here uh we'll get
we'll get to it we'll get to it if you
want to pull my model up and let's do a
couple versions your model is already
loaded my friend so uh I have uh this is
uh a stable diffusion automatic 1111 and
up here are your checkpoints or your
models and I have one dedicated to Clint
and I can put in the command word uh
client
x-e-i-o man and then if I hit generate
an image that is roughly Clint on a
couch how rare and unusual that like a
corridor shirt like
do the worst clapping there now this is
it you know this is a perfect full
screen
Adam uh this is a perfect clearly the
face is
um you know leaves a lot to be desired
but for me typing in a single sentence
or a single command phrase and then
getting an image that if you squinted or
got shown this pretty wow dude I've
always wanted a red motorcycle
like your legs like there's some stuff
going on here but yeah it's like looks
like some
that's you on a motorcycle if you squint
100 uh so let's start let's go a little
fancier right I'm gonna try
a fancier prompt I've once saved here
let's see if this works so
I'm gonna put
craziness dude
I'm getting comfy with someone I'm gonna
try to make you a Victorian detective I
don't want to see what you would look
like as like you know uh uh you're
you're trying to solve a murderer where
is Jack the Ripper
um and let's see what that is I'm gonna
put the batch count up because it seems
like uh generating one image at a time
is that much fun yeah cause like you
were saying by the way so Jan I Gotta
Give shout outs to you Jan like you
you've got me set up on this this week
so like I I didn't know anything before
this week and
like I I first off thank you
again
um what what's what's batch count how
why do you do a batch account as opposed
to one Ops
so so uh uh when you're this deep into
AI art especially um uh with some like
home brewed checkpoints and stable
diffusion uh you kind of have to uh you
have to generate a lot of images to find
ones that work uh uh for what you were
aiming for uh and because it's so fast
and and you know relatively uh processor
uh light uh you want to generate as as
many as you can can can stand to wait
for so down here I've put the batch
count up to three with a batch size of
two meaning it'll make uh uh uh two
images three separate times right
um
so we have a lot of Clint uh perhaps a
little it's uh this is probably the best
one but we're losing Clinton there but
again if you squinted and looked at that
that's a Victorian era uh Clint what me
okay oh boy
oh man oh man on the full screen some
clowns there no dude
oh no dude I wish my beard was that
pointy it like gets all uh yeah
some sort of Christmas Pikmin Katamari
thing
good
oh man this is guys if
it's point
if you're not realizing how insane this
is like you could literally do anything
this is dangerous yeah the second egg
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um the second
uh you can dream it and you figure out a
little bit of prompt crafting uh you
could you could start to zero in and
just with the uh a couple of uh
sentences you can do some real damage
oh no
bro uh what's interesting here what what
jumps to me is that it remember it found
my nose right yeah dude I find it loses
the nose ring a lot just because it as
as the program's reaching into latent
space not a lot of faces have nose rings
so it it it it tends to struggle
bringing that informed but that's that's
great man I think I think people get the
idea we're gonna come back to this and
we're going to go ham there's so many
different styles we can do like 3D
character versions of us we can do voxel
art we could do anime we could do Arcane
characters we could do Warhammer 40K
characters we could do us with big butts
do you do anything you could do anything
it's insane what's possible that's a
decent sketch of you
um
that's pretty good
oh Victorian area you sure that's pretty
that hair is starting to get
whoa
that's so good
we're gonna yeah I mean we're gonna get
into like combining Styles we're gonna
we'll get into like how to put you and
your friend in the same art but let's
let's put a bookmark in this right now
let's hop over to mid-journey
and let's kind of talk through prompts
just a little bit and let's um let's
also blender Guru just put out a
tutorial like two days ago on how to do
kind of this with uh with mid-journey I
didn't know about it so we'll kind of
walk you guys through and by the way
um if you if you don't know at this
point I do have a Discord server
it's linked in the description you gotta
scroll down a little bit like join the
community if you go to the Discord
server
um there's going to be
a few mid-journey channels here where
you guys can go and actually get
creating
um in mid Journey so let me see if I
can't pull this
oh this also confusing I have like so
many tabs open
yeah yeah welcome to air oh man
um pop this out get this over here
uh so on the left here you see mid
Journey one two and oh you can't even
see that yet
so I gotta re resize all this stuff
on the left
mid Journey one two and three you guys
hop in there and kind of get creating
yourselves we're gonna guide you through
if you've never done this before or if
your mid Journey Pro will hop in and
help guide people yourself show them
what the good command uh what the good
prompts are
a hundred percent yeah because it's a
you know mid-journey's been around for a
while if you're a creative chances are
you've at least uh opened it up and
tried to mess around with it
um clearly the more the more time you
spend in and around AI artist you start
to pick up a lot of tips and tricks uh a
really good prompts um you know most of
the community is very open to this idea
of Open Source and like sharing and and
getting uh getting everyone kind of up
to speed uh one of one of the big claims
that uh imrad uh the the uh founder of
uh stable diffusion uh uh he's
constantly stating imagine the world
with the billion artists right imagine
getting you know a face like this as
easily as hitting enter for a billion
people imagine just a way cooler World
Imagine everyone being a rabbit a rad
artist
um yeah it would be like literacy now
right like way back back of the day
literacy was a a rare thing that only
certain people had now everyone can read
right at least almost everyone I hope
all of you can um so I will say you can
read
um I was pretty I'm Not skeptical but I
was hesitant with all this AI stuff
especially the art side of things
because we're all artists and we don't
want our jobs taken obviously right so
um I was at
um half res in Chicago and there was a
gentleman whose name I should know he I
believe is the guy the CEO of school of
motion oh my goodness I hope I get that
right
oh won't produce water bottle I [ __ ]
love that guy oh good old good old looks
ah the best yeah he but he gave the
greatest
presentation of all time he basically
put everyone in the room at ease and he
was like look we've been through this
before we have gone through the thing
where like
all these Advanced artists who had these
really expensive programs back in the
day
um had After Effects come out it was the
cheap solution and now everyone can do
what they did oh no we're gonna lose our
jobs
um but honestly it just allowed more
people to create and
that it's just we got into a business
that is upgrading constantly it's
updating constantly so like you gotta
kind of upgrade an update with the times
and
right now ai art is insane and as an
artist like
when I was first when I was first
graduating uh when I graduated Film
School uh uh dslrs that were powerful
enough uh to to record a 1080 image had
just come out the 7D had just dropped
the 5D had just dropped and I remember
the pushback from so-called you know
real filmmakers going well you can't
make real art with that thing and what
uh I'm sorry but what kind of what a
dumb Viewpoint right like uh you you can
make real good art with your phone
um I I I've been seeing a dude on uh
Reddit using a Game Boy
um uh camera and doing panoramics with
that right that's a radical yeah radical
so how is that not art right how are
who's gatekeeping this and kind of screw
you if you are
um well in this community together
um let's let's actually talk about uh
mid-journey a little bit uh I won't bore
you guys with too many of the details on
how this is working but uh uh uh a lot
of people
um just from the get-go think of it as
okay it's just a computer taking images
from online photoshopping them real
quick and putting them in front of you
and if that was actually happening my
God how powerful of a program that would
be right an automatic Photoshop like uh
are you petting a kitten this is Teddy
sorry to cut you off sorry extension
I I got uh uh I I uh uh uh rightfully
got distracted by a cat so are you you I
I coach I totally derailed you just then
I'm I'm just trying to get through uh
what what is happening here when I hit
uh uh I just went with the prompt a man
uh hesitating fearfully from AI art uh
this guy looks a little I like number
three here so I'm gonna hit you three by
the way which is up I'm we're gonna be
throwing stuff at you guys hit um
forward slash imagine and type whatever
you want uh that's how mid Journey works
that's the basics sure yes uh uh you're
you're you're queuing up the program uh
to to add in your prompt thus you uh hit
backslash and then a man or you could
type and imagine and it'll give you this
little uh highlight prompt uh area and
then you type in whatever you want and
then there's there's some stuff you can
do on the back end so what you're seeing
right now is uh the the mid-journey bot
going through different uh steps it is
it is waiting a lot of gaussian noise
against each other to to create an image
now roughly what that means is there's a
space called latent space all of uh uh
it's billions of images have been
trained into latent space and they've
basically been exploded into just pixels
right this is uh just pixels right it's
five five twelve by 512 pixels uh I
believe on a mid Journey standard
um and what what the the bot is doing is
going uh it's going into latent space
which is this kind of hard thing to
imagine it's a a a a multi-dimensional
space with a bunch of values put in
there and everything uh every word has a
value inside of latent space that is
made up of uh math essentially right uh
zeros and ones and a man can be
represented by a lot of different spaces
in latent space so each one of these
words is weighted and then all those
little Sands all those little pixels are
slammed together and thus you get this
uh image now I know you're immediately
saying well what if I just type that
same thing in again right uh uh will it
be identical
and the answer is no absolutely uh the
answer is no I'm going to put the exact
same uh prompt in right I've hit uh
backslash imagine prompt a man
hesitating fearfully from Air enter now
once again the bot is going absolutely
let me let me go collect all this and
this the pixels that are all weighted uh
on values that have been predetermined
when the model was trained so
um yeah another thing to think about
especially as you generate is uh
mid-journey is not free
um there is a subscription to this uh it
is very server and processor intensive
so uh the reason mid-journey is as
popular as it is is because the results
are almost always uh pretty good and
it's very easy to approach right it's on
Discord you'll probably already on
Discord before you started uh uh working
in in mid Journey uh we can already see
that the the images are vastly different
right none of these this one's sweet uh
none of these even remotely right
there's a dude there's technology he
seems to be uh uh not thrilled about it
and each one of these is a an original
uh a fully original novel piece of art
and I could do this
essentially forever I could uh keep
typing this in and it will a lot of them
will be similar of course but it will
excuse me never produce the same piece
of art twice Jan let's do it let's
challenge each other let's do a thing
where we have a goal in mind and we're
trying to we're trying to create
something and let's try and tweak the
prompt to get us closer to that
something so I love it I love it a
lesson in prompt craft uh uh real quick
before we do that let's get our settings
uh let's get all of our ducks in a row
right that's it backslash and then right
down here you'll have settings or you
could just type in probably s will bring
it up right uh or just type it yeah so
I'm gonna hit enter twice
confused on that
um
and I didn't know like this is you know
I I've only messed with mid-journey to
the point kind of what I showed you guys
just now
um if you guys have any questions like
technical questions on what we're doing
right now and how to get to the point
we're at right now hit me in the live
chat at Punisher so I can see you I'll
do my best to like you know I'm doing
three things at once here but of course
hit me there
um also there are there are a bunch of
guides
um and and you know uh there's a reason
we're here we're all here to learn I'm
constantly learning this stuff is moving
a mile a minute every day I'm waking up
to new new advancements and you have to
just kind of be aware that oftentimes
you're gonna you're gonna hit a dead end
or a wall and just have to have to go
down a uh Google uh uh search and mid
journey is great to hold on I'll just
say it real quick mid journey is really
nice because it's very user friendly
um the stable diffusion stuff that we're
gonna be getting into that you guys saw
at the beginning here like
it's some hair pulling stuff to get set
up so the thing that's so nice about
mid-journey is that it's very accessible
um it's very easy to use yes you do pay
for it
um for me personally I say that's
totally worth it what I've used before
100 yeah yeah like what I've used it for
in the past is
I think the most obvious thing for me is
to generate concept art to guide my my
art so you guys have seen this in the
last like big art breakdown I did with
that like VR room inside of that
warehouse I used mid-journey to create
um concept art for that scene as well as
you know you know Studio Ghibli style
watercolor images to fill the VR screen
with so they're great it's a great tool
to like supplement your art with
um
and to just brainstorm and kind of get
yeah and just yeah get get uh exactly
get a uh get get some uh get get the the
gray juices flowing and that big old
Noggin of yours
um yeah and mid Journeys also their
their models have always been uh uh
their models have a cool factor that a
lot of the other uh big platforms such
as dolly or even uh stable diffusion uh
mid-journey just every time you hit
enter it's a banging piece of uh artwork
uh yeah it's it it has always had that
Genesis of Just What A rad What A rad
thing and for 30 bucks a month uh which
I go I burn through all the time but
again I'm I'm In Too Deep uh let's uh
let's go over some of these settings
right because some of this might make
sense MJ version
guess what that's the mid-journey
version uh this week right it came out
this week or something uh yeah uh MJ
version four just dropped it's actually
very limited it can only give you a
square currently whereas if we jump back
to version three we'll be able to do
wides or tall frames and you'll be able
to to work with the image uh in a way
that uh version four cannot do right now
if you're watching this one week after
the fact it's probably already been
implemented you're already there good
job well done but for right now just
because version four is very uh pleasing
we're gonna we're gonna set it to
version four uh down here we have MJ
test and MJ test photo this was version
3.5
um and basically MJ test was an artistic
version and MJ photo test or test photo
is uh a photo uh it was all trained on
photography so if you're looking
specifically for a very high quality
photo without doing much prompting I
would click there
but again right now let's just stick
with version four uh half Quality Base
quality and high quality uh all reflects
your tokens or how expensive it'll be if
you really want to milk it go down to
half quality you can even go lower than
that
um by looking up uh uh quality settings
I believe it's Dash queue and you can go
to point one but at that at that point
you're just looking at you know uh
low-rise pixels
um over here are the Styles and this uh
uh uh this is a fun thing to play around
with the less style you have the more
like your prompt it'll be the more
stylized it is the more uh the the the
pro the bot will have fun with it
um these are upscaling options uh beta
upscales very popular uh but it does
burn uh a good amount of um your credit
so I'm just gonna leave it on regular
upscale for the moment uh public mode
again chat chances are you're probably
I've only ever come across one AI artist
who was very precious about their
prompts and you know what cool
um uh relax mode down here will be far
less intensive to your uh credit usage
uh it'll take a lot longer to get your
results back but if you're okay with
that if you um you know I I did a but I
went and I had some dental work done and
I was doing art while I was just sitting
in the dentist chair
um and I had flipped it over to relax
mode because there's only you know so
active I can be at that point uh remix
mode we'll get into a minute right now
let's just uh let's just have some fun
with prompting let's do it yeah so I I
learned a few months back at that
Chicago event at half res that you can
do
like seamless textures so if we type
forward slash imagine right hit enter
you're queued up to prompt and we can
type like concrete
texture
um and I believe it's top down I think
is the the prompt to get that I was
thinking I was trying like bird's eye
view
um
I don't think that worked uh I think
it's top down it's been a minute since
I've done it I can always look at my
history but we'll see if this works
there's actually a lot of ways of making
repeating Textures in air there's
actually just a tiling option in stable
diffusion there's there's a lot of ways
of making uh again something very handy
to you guys that are making digital
scenes or or a video game making
something that tiles for like a sunset
in the background is very easy through
through AI art so yeah all right so top
down looks like it was the one and I
think if you add seamless it will also
make it seamless
um because these don't
they they almost look like they'll
they'll tile sure yeah
um
prompt wise Jan can you type can you do
like negative prompts can you say no
grass if I want the grass out of this
bottom left one
yeah yeah so uh uh I would grab that
prompt
um yeah and hit dash dash no
uh behind or in front uh let's do a
little test whoop Dash Dash
no no grass
and then again for Moss right no Moss
sure try that out all right
and you could bring this in to I mean
there's a million different programs to
create normal Maps I'm I'm a little less
informed on that side of things but you
could bring it into Photoshop I know and
make a normal map you can upscale these
with mid Journey so these use
stands for upscale so U1 right it's one
two three four right so you can upscale
one two three and four depending on
which one you want or you can do a
different version of one two three and
four so if you kind of like the vibe of
this bottom right one you can click V4
and it's going to create four more it's
going to create another tile of kind of
based off of this bottom right image so
that way you can it's almost like Google
search image where you just keep
getting closer and closer to kind of
what you're looking for and you can see
here yeah no grass no Moss it's top down
um is it seamless that is a little
harder to figure out
it doesn't this one does not look
seamless
no I mean
you put a blur over it maybe hmm okay so
ancient chaos says the second Dash Dash
it doesn't count so they say okay it's
just one per well you can keep chaining
it with the commas it looks like so it'd
be dash dash no grass comma no Moss
comma no you know whatever yeah yeah for
sure so between all your
um uh uh all your your prompt commands
you should each like thought should be
uh closed off with a comma and when we
get to stable diffusion there's a few
other ways of sort of uh uh
communicating with it but this is a way
of learning your
um uh uh how you're communicating with
the EP program right
let's try like something crazy uh
hmm what's a crazy texture like obsidian
oh I'm trying bark
obsidian texture
seamless
top down
and then we'll do Dash well we don't
know what so Jen you were talking about
the other day you kind of start simple
with your prompts that's your style you
start simple and then you add from there
right and then start working your way up
from there right like I went from uh um
you know uh we we had tree texture top
down stainless now wood texture bark top
down seamless highly detailed uh and
then repeating right
competing a tile uh let's try that out
right
um and then slow surely you'll start to
start to find some super cool prompts
I'm gonna throw a big old uh dumb piece
to
um nonsense at you because uh let's say
uh you'll see that's a lot sort of
floating around the servers
um uh because it's a great way of
learning how prompt craft is just going
on to the mid Journey uh generals and
sort of seeing what other people are are
doing on there and you know uh there's
no real theft in here all right you just
kind of borrow people's problems and uh
with it so if I want to do a mains a
face and then I wanted to really put a
lot of sauce on there I would hit it
with a whole bunch of nonsense like
let me actually make sure this copy dude
this looks so cool
um so quick shout out oh look at that
Edis Edis you're saying that uh V4 mid
Journey V4 doesn't do seamless so I'd
have to go back to Visa three okay which
is yeah I I thought you know I was
actually worried that the nose wouldn't
work in V4 because V4 is very limited
um produces some banging results but
yeah it's a it's a wee bit limited I'm
gonna give it a shot I'm gonna see do
that do it
obsidian texture seamless top down
um HD
yeah let's see what that does for us
thank you I appreciate everybody here
like I learned so much from you guys in
the chat like throughout you know for
the two and a half years I've been doing
these streams y'all are always hitting
me with good info I really appreciate it
so I I do learn a lot from you guys I
know texture sites rip it's scary it is
scary seriously
um
yeah it's like what what what frightens
you about that right well here's the
thing I was actually talking with with
um with Andrew blender Guru
um he came down to La for an event and
we got dinner together and we were
talking about all this craziness if you
guys don't know blender Guru the donut
guy he owns polygon they're they're a
website that
you know sells textures and 3D models
right so I I and he's into AI I asked
him like how do you feel about this you
know and you know he was like well how
can we use this how can we use this
technology to keep growing and I'm like
dude that's the great mindset to have
man
you're never gonna you're never going to
win the battle against Tech right
um uh uh uh for all the um
uh uh God what's his name uh um John uh
guy with the hammer uh uh just turn of
the century story about uh people
fighting industrialization
last year gosh dang it uh my historical
references uh if I could uh John Henry
uh good old John Henry tried to
outperform you know uh uh uh trading
workers and he did a great job good on
him uh we're we're always using
technology right you have already
started seeing Implement implementation
of AI into every thing from from the way
you text on your phone to uh uh uh uh
upresing or stabilization you know topaz
the topaz Labs software is all AI
generated right
um and as much as I I love Mr blender
Guru taught me how to do blender uh much
love to you uh maybe we don't need
texture libraries anymore right like now
we've got a thing to solve that I I uh I
crave the day when I can make a
feature-length film that's as good as
anything James Cameron made from the
comfort of my own home
um you know that's the whole statement
that's a bold statement because a lot of
people feel that the craft will be lost
and the hard work that they put in to
learning their craft like a lifetime
generation's worth of energy put into
all of this is now just so easy you can
just poop it out hit enter and make a
masterpiece like what you know what's to
say about that
so there's a similar argument when
photography comes around uh you can
actually find these you know even even
uh I think there was a uh uh uh an
argument made in the uh in 2015 of
whether photography should be included
in museums as art
um there's always you know our
subjective to what you to to each viewer
and if there is a craft there I think
you you know uh uh uh uh making a
stop-motion animated film has a craft
and a a really really cool Dynamic to it
I think you're still gonna see that I
don't think you're going to see 300
million dollars going into that anymore
and is that a bad thing right I
understand it's scary what happens when
the AI is so good that anyone could do
it well there's gonna be a lot of uh uh
a lot of art out there and I'm not sure
you know I'm not sure that's a bad thing
I don't think just be just because
education got real good and then books
started getting around and a whole
population went from not being able to
read to being able to read that was a
real big positive right I think as we
educate the non-artistic people when if
my mom mom was as good of an artist as
me how is that a bad thing I love my mom
I love your mom the moms are great let's
get them all
you could do a live stream where it's
our moms doing the a like the promises
I mean right now it would be insane
especially when we get to stable
diffusion uh trying to walk my mom
through how to install oh my God okay
there's a layer of hell that exists for
that um I'm getting uh a little
distracted hold on uh
um so I will mention this right it is
scary
to think that
we could make less money because of this
right and it's like oh no my living I I
get that 100 I don't think it's
happening now maybe it's happening next
year I don't know I I really don't know
but you know what um let's see who was
who said this here in the chat you know
a lot of you guys are saying that
you're just better off if you know the
technology and you can utilize it better
than anyone else so it's like know that
this is a tool
have fun have fun with it and also at
the same time just because like there's
this fear of The Craft going away
doesn't mean it it needs to go away like
it I think it all comes down to
happiness what makes you happy what's
fun for you do that thing you know like
just if air is not your thing you don't
have to you don't have to do it that's
fine
um
think about painting on walls has been
around pretty much since we've had
culture that still happens right people
are still painting on walls so it's not
like oh we got spray paint cans now and
we got paint so easy you don't have to
mix you know Cerulean you don't you you
didn't mix your own paints you call
yourself an artist like it all of that
kind of uh falls falls flat to me
um uh uh yeah I I even think the art of
Cinema what what do I really do when I'm
making a movie I'm sitting behind a big
expense piece of technology and glass
and I'm telling a crew of people who are
going to be credited less than me
um what to do
where's the I I guess to me the once you
actually start making the uh uh the
sausage
um making the sausage in here just is
way easier uh so real quick may this was
wood texture bark top down seamless
highly detailed repeating tile yeah
we've got some pretty nice little Marks
here right those are nice
I then added just to start us off a
highly detailed key visuals RTX uh 6K
render Unreal Engine ultra realistic
post-production shaders Octane
volumetric and look at that we're
starting to get some um oh I think that
took it away we're starting to get some
I we're we're losing the um texture
right we're losing that but you're
starting to see what these what these
command prompts are able to do
um and what a lot of people do I'm not
the biggest fan of it but people will
bomb uh um bomb all their prompts with a
huge list of you know sort of these
these magical qualifiers that will make
your work better very popular ones are
trending on a uh art station
um uh that trending on Art station is
very popular uh art by we haven't
actually done it yet which I'm kind of
proud We haven't used an artist's name
yet but some people you know go to town
on that and I'm not sure it feels a
little icky right now when I just dump
you know if I use one or two artists
okay I'm trying to find a style when I'm
just dumping them in like you know
[ __ ] command prompts
that's starting to get a little more uh
um problematic but that might just be my
brain holding on to again even what I'm
what I'm worried about there's the whole
like
argument and worry about
stealing people's art to go into this
pool of art right and like
everyone's got their opinion on it
personally I think it's for the greater
good it's just like a public library
kind of where it's all it's all just in
there and we're all helping the
technology grow like I'm down for that I
do know that some people are like I
don't want my art included in this
yeah I mean it's like
so there's actually a pretty interesting
Court ruling that happened about three
weeks ago I can I can dump the link to
it I I saved it I can dump a link to it
somewhere so you can all see it but
basically uh 10 years ago roughly uh the
writer's Guild of America realized that
Google was training their novel AI or I
believe I believe it was just a a pretty
rudimentary
um uh uh uh uh AI Bill training it on uh
people's novels right and people got
real mad so they took it they knocked it
around court and uh
it took up forever it took nearly 10
years for it to finally land on a
decision no one wanted to rule on it
right uh you the courts didn't want to
get in the way of new technology that's
based in America the uh writers uh you
know it's very complicated and roughly
what they came up with uh was that if
you didn't invent the language and you
didn't invent key aspects of how to
write the language you cannot prevent
people from using it for an educational
purpose and so that that is just shy of
uh the Supreme Court a second Circuit
Court of uh appeals landed on that
decision that as far as training
a word based AI if you are using a
language that you didn't invent
uh good luck trying to get that good
luck getting the law on your side uh and
it's you know it's tough because I could
see both sides of the argument if I
wrote a novel and uh it went to this
greater thing I didn't understand maybe
I'd be a little a little bothered by it
but at the same time I think we
culturally are gonna have to really
start battling with the question of
ownership I think this is a bigger
conversation uh around what what is
yours right uh if you make an a 3D
object in a program that you didn't
build
where where is that line right like
where where uh uh I I think it's really
interesting so these are starting to
look real realistic again not textures
but that looks like wood to me number
two there we should we should wrap out
mid-journey here and move on to stable
diffusion here so real quick let's do a
uh let's do a quick
um uh let's do what uh Mr Guru uh showed
us about image damage so I'm gonna go
back into settings
I'm going to turn on
to enters I'm going to turn on remix
mode over here right I'll leave
everything else uh the same I yeah
that's all fine so you're essentially
able there's a link in the description
that I have for you guys
um and it is like how to create your
likeness in mid-journey it's a tutorial
from blender Guru and
um it came out like two days ago I
didn't even know you could do this but
basically like we're gonna get into it
later in stable diffusion how you can
kind of upload your likeness and train a
model on your likeness
um but it's pretty darn simple in
mid-journey which is amazing
so so yeah actually mid-journey
it's not I think pretty much uh uh since
version two you've had some form of
image to image which is uh what were
what we're we're talking about here and
it's gotten much better over the time
but uh uh let's just do a quick test so
this is my friend Dean uh this is when
Dean uh uh uh took a pretty pretty bad
spill on a thing called Boy Scout wall
out in New Jack City doing some rock
climbing
um pretty pretty Fine Photo I'm gonna
drag this into uh Discord I'm not gonna
put it onto
uh um uh currently I'm on a private um I
I'm I'm on I'm just communicating with
uh the Discord bot but there it is look
at that look at that photo of my friend
Dean so I'm gonna click to enlarge that
I'm gonna go over here to open original
which is right under it uh that's going
to bring up the the photo uh in a web
browser I'm going to copy the uh Link at
the top I'm gonna copy that down and
then I'm gonna come back to that is not
Discord I'm going to come back to
Discord and I'm going to engage imagine
backslash imagine I'm going to paste
that and then I'm going to add something
uh fun right
um as a cartoon right so it is now using
that photo as a reference and then I
have engaged remix mode so it knows it's
going to try to take that image and
recreate it in some fun way so I'm just
going to put as a cartoon simple prompt
nothing else no no 50 millimeters no
highly details no trending on Art
station no made by Greg rutakowski or
however you say his name
um by the way before AI art had no idea
who he was no idea who he was
okay and now we are loading uh this guy
once again it's probably gonna take a
minute but um
oh this is great it's
it's so much fun
uh a couple cool things about oh okay
we're starting to see it it's starting
to dig into uh latent space and pull out
pixels to match this image right uh so
we got Dean up here and you know uh uh
down here we've got a uh some
interesting versions of cartoon Dean
we're getting that he's in front of a
mountain uh it's kind of made a house
for the first image it's also given Dean
a hell of a dominant nose over here it
turns him into like definitely more of a
feminine features yeah for sure for sure
he's got a
um you know he's got he's got some
feminine uh features happening here but
when we look at this and come down to
this you
th similarities right I mean clearly
this model has been influenced by the uh
photo up here right that top right
picture
uh now another and uh perhaps we should
be jumping over to
um uh stable diffusion but another way
you could sort of uh control the the
where the bot is looking if we were to
do this again I could use uh uh uh if I
felt like the cartoon wasn't being hit
up enough I could do the same thing
again and this might be a thing that uh
uh worked in version three and is
currently unavailable and four I
actually haven't checked yet
um uh uh but I'm going to put same image
as a cartoon
and then I'm going to put colon colon uh
let's put five right and so that those
colons and that five at least for
version three and before would would add
weight to that word so that uh if if
let's say you have a photo you're trying
to translate you wanted to put
sunglasses on yourself and it just
wasn't it really wasn't doing the
sunglasses I would start messing around
with uh some of those qualifiers and and
starting to get into some some of the
deeper aspects of mid-journey
kind of why mid journey is the the best
why I prefer it uh for web UI over Dolly
every time you sort of pull the trigger
it's good it can be as simple as an
image as a cartoon and this is great
this is better than I could have drawn
right this is great way great
um yeah so now it's giving me even more
cartoonage on a Dean uh yeah dude it
straight up made with our cat oh because
I put cat I put cat tune uh not cartoons
that's hilarious
dude uh but that's so good it made him a
toony cat with a uh there here's
kathmandine
dude left the bottom left yeah bottom
left is incredible
like original
um Jumanji that's hilarious
um let's let's move on yeah for sure for
sure I could again I could ramble about
late in space my whole life so
um all right let's hop back so basically
um that's mid-journey in a nutshell
there's a lot more to dive into there's
a lot of like little prompts that you
guys can add to the end of or little
like things to add to the end of your
prompts and you know just head to the
mid Journey website it's linked in the
description below
um and there's also a
there there's a lot of prompt guides out
there if you if you find yourself
sitting there like I'm real good at 3D
software but not real good at forming
sentences that can communicate with this
computer uh so there they I don't know
if I'm bringing my pick up real quick
but there are like here's the thing
called Lexia
thank you there's a thing called
uh
right here's a thing called Lexia and
this is just this is specifically for
stable diffusion but there are versions
of this for mid-journey you can just
kind of scroll through and let's say I
really like this night guy right I can
click on this guy it'll bring it up
it'll give me the prompt uh I can then
just click copy prompt it also gives you
the seed which we'll get into why that's
important and there you go you now have
everything you need to make that uh uh
image through stable diffusion uh or mid
journey I mean swap swap prompts
sometimes it uh leads to some cool
results and you know it's as easy as uh
uh picking picking certain key phrases
and just starting to see uh starting to
see the code as you look at uh images
right
um uh sea of a blood uh sea of Blood on
the moon
I mean that's starting to look like it
right that's something
um real cool yeah there's a whole movie
you know you're only limited by your
imagination with all this so it's it's
crazy
it's it's it's freaking nuts it's it's a
great thing to use for concepting right
now like there are there is video but
we're not gonna really get into that on
the stream we actually our our homie is
over at Corridor Digital uh uh Nico Dean
and I believe Runner um they might have
something cooking up for you tomorrow uh
stay tuned watch the corridor and uh
maybe you'll see how [ __ ] close we
are to uh text to video you know uh
there's also we won't get into it today
but there's also text to 3D object but
it is
experimental so yeah it's just it's just
a blast off this it's you could do
anything with all this stuff it's being
developed as we speak so Jan here here's
what I want to do
um you taught me how to get stable
diffusion up and running I am going to
try and recommunicate that for people on
the stream let me know if I do a good
job of course this is a test for myself
to see if I get it right and I'll be
following along to make sure we're uh
yeah we're we're doing we're doing good
all right so here's what I'm gonna do
for y'all
um let's see here all right all right
all right so let me switch over
um
all right this is my desktop
there's a there's a few things y'all are
going to want to download this is where
we want to get to we want to get to this
point where you see this page right here
it is incredibly powerful
um oh yeah it's kind of like mid-journey
with I'm not gonna say the training
wheels off but
you have a lot more control over what
you're creating you can paint out
certain parts of the image
um and replace it with whatever you want
you can bring your own images in you can
create images based off of other images
it's it's nuts and all these sliders
kind of help you determine in these
different
um these different sampling methods help
you determine uh more specifically the
image you're trying to get so to get
this right and eventually to get that
whole like your likeness up onto this
thing we'll get to that but let me just
try and get you guys to the point where
you have this downloaded so
the first thing you're gonna want to
download is the
uh stable diffusion automatic 11 11. if
you type that into Google there's a
GitHub link it's in the description on
the title if you're not right
if you're not familiar with GitHub Now's
the Time to get familiar with uh get
getting onto uh GitHub page there's kind
of a it might look like Matrix code if
you were gonna pay before it can be a
little daunting so we have this in the
description for you guys
um and it's basically the GitHub always
confused me but it's this top right the
code if you download the zip it'll
download the code right and you're going
to
um and what just real quick what you're
downloading right now is a a third party
made a guy named automatic 1111 uh I
can't imagine that's his birth name but
who knows
um what you're looking at is he made a
fork of some uh uh some some some open
source made software and he made
basically the best web UI that can run
uh the models that stable diffusion uh
uh uh that that stable diffusion made
um all right sorry sorry oh good just
wanted to wanted to to give some context
to what you're doing right now and just
to just to let you guys know mid-journey
is
paid it's 30 bucks a month this is free
it's just a little bit harder to uh you
know to get up and running but and and
technically the easiest way if you don't
want to deal with any of this if you
just I want to use stable diffusions
model I don't want to deal with this I
have money to throw around
uh you can just go to dream Studio it's
their official it's it's their official
API uh uh it it doesn't currently have a
lot of the very fun features we'll be
covering today but it is if you don't
want to deal with any of this nonsense
just go on to dream studio and have fun
there and we got you with the link in
the description as well so once you
download this this is pretty much like
the exe this is going to be what you're
gonna to run uh you're gonna you're
gonna run this to open up like this web
browser here that I'm looking at right
now but there's a couple more things you
need
um you're gonna need the model right
because it all is all based on like
prior training of a bunch of bunch of
faces a bunch of art a bunch of
everything
um and that's the model so what you're
going to look up also linked in the
description
um is
the if you go to hugging face
um and if you look up on hugging face
if you first things first you're gonna
have to get you're gonna have to get an
account you need an account it's free
it's free it's fine but this is in the
description the stable diffusion uh 1.5
there's gonna be like a little check
like you're gonna scroll down to this
open GitHub repository you're going to
download these weights right here the
the pruned and modeling
um thing here basically that is um
that's what you want grab that you're
gonna grab that model but you gotta log
in right and you also right up in this
area there's going to be like little
check box it says I accept I was having
the hardest time yesterday a couple days
ago where it was like it wouldn't let me
download it because I needed to hit like
check box okay and then you can download
this this is the library
this file here this four gig file is
like the library that the program is
using to reference everything that
you're it's going to be creating right
so you download that
yeah that's that's basically the brain
or the soul of uh uh of of the AI art
here it was um really cool of stable
diffuse no other company has just
released their model like that thing
represents
hundreds of millions of hours worth of
uh processing work and and just a lot of
money and they just went here you go
take it have fun and what a cool damn
decision
um yeah
so from there you're going to have a
folder
called stable diffusion web UI master
and that is going to be that first file
we download all the stuff is in the
description for you guys oh it's all in
the description you're going to open
this up you're going to see this it's a
bunch of files you're gonna be like what
the heck is all of this
um for context this file here this web
UI user.bat that's what you're going to
run to like boot the web UI all right
but we're we're gonna get there in a
second the the model that you just
downloaded that version 1.5 you're just
going to drop that in the models folder
under stable diffusion this is where all
your models go and this is that 1.5 the
pruned e-monli file you're gonna drop
that in right there
um so that you're pretty much ready to
go you're gonna run this web UI user.bat
I already ran it
um It's Gonna Give You well you know
what let's just do it because yeah do it
get through it all right so I'm going to
close close this
um now if you run this it's going to
open
a this is python could be a command a
command uh
so
it's gonna run and and you're going to
run into problems here I guarantee you
you're going to run into problems here
and it's going to ask you to download a
bunch of stuff so things like
things I didn't ever never even heard of
like hip and uh yeah sure and and all
this all this random crap is going to
ask you for and you kind of have to just
go through and be like all right this is
the next thing I gotta download this
next thing I gotta download but in the
description I got you with the things I
had to download to do this first off
you've got to download python which is
like a recording language
I would also this will probably take
care of a lot of problems I would just
while you're at it get anaconda and mini
conda chances are those two will uh just
installing those will bring along some
of the missing items that you might not
have already so that might be a fix that
just you didn't even think about that's
just like Lord knows that might yeah so
that that's also a thing Anaconda also
in the description for you guys to
download that's basically another way to
read Python's coding language easier to
mess with it easier
um
so you got that right and then I needed
to download something called get what
the heck is git I don't know what git is
but I needed it in order to do this
um and it will tell you when you're
reading this stuff here when you're
reading this Matrix code you know you
read it line by line and it's like oh
you got to get git right
so
jump jump into Google put it there
um and start to troubleshoot absolute
absolute worst case scenario if uh if
even by the end of the stream you
haven't figured it out
there is a very dedicated Community for
stable diffusion you can head over there
you know on Discord
um
yeah there's a big like the akashic
files of a Reddit link yeah everything
you'll ever need also in the description
you got you guys know by this point it's
down there the Reddit link it has
tutorials and walkthroughs of all this
stuff if you get lost but I'm just
trying to get you everything that I got
stuck on right now
um once you run this right when you
click this webuser.bat you got your
model loaded in here you're gonna be
presented with this link and it's as
easy as copying this link and
um we open up another instance of
here we go I'm gonna paste it in there
hit enter and it's going to pull up the
UI if you can get to this point
party it's party time like party time
yeah you're you're Off to the Races you
freaking did it um I find it's good to
keep
um your command prompt open uh because
when you play the music from The Matrix
and you have a command prompt open
you're officially a hacker you might not
know that but you've officially become a
hacker when you're looking at a command
prompt and stuff is going my God how
cool it's taken this many years of your
life to officially be a hacker welcome
to the club guys welcome we were up till
one last night like with Matrix music
and Nico was over at Jan's Place yeah
and he was like sitting on my couch
trying to help us get this thing done oh
yeah because it's it's much much up to
our Corridor Brethren um yeah seriously
it's some hair pulling stuff but if you
can get to this point right here here
it's two thumbs up and like you're
pretty much there
um
so we can do
I mean let's let's just make something
try running something yeah try running
something all right I'm gonna take this
100 sample steps up to 30 and it changes
to ddim I'm gonna take the batch count
up to three and
um
Let's Go full screen with this thing
sure
all right
drop you guys in the description drop me
some stuff what do you want me to throw
in here I'll throw it in
yeah also just so you know mid-journey
uh has a lot of uh censorship uh rules
as does the the web uh or the the uh
dream Studio as does Dolly they all kind
of don't let you go nuts
oh automatic 11-11 go nuts you can uh
you could put so many genitals on your
face oh my you could make your just face
full of genitals um we won't be doing
that on the stream I promise you so I
can put it on you're no fun you know
that not not fun at all I think it's
more the algorithm sure
um I will put in the negative prompts
nude so we don't get demonized yes while
we're live so stream does not get what
what's happening with uh negative
problems what's a negative prompt
well negative prompt is things that it
doesn't include I'm going to type Kirby
and hit generate someone said okay nice
nice diverse green
Anon said do Kirby so we're doing Kirby
not nude Kirby
dude that's a freaking Kirby ball if I
ever seen one
oh yeah
Kirby in this weird language I'm gonna
Lord Clint
all right so for that I need to change
the model to my model that has been
trained on me we'll show you guys how to
do that in a second but we're gonna have
a little bit of fun here in the program
we're also going to talk about some
sliders and stuff so I had to switch it
to me right so if I type lowered
who knows what's going to happen Lord
and then my keyword is clintonius
Lord clintonius
sitting atop a throne
let's generate that and see what happens
oh a kitten Mage I like kitten Mage ooh
that's fun
being what I'm trying to make Kirby
eating God
[Laughter]
oh you know what I am negative prompting
cartoon I should probably try to take
that out let me switch back to both of
us here
her
oh
hypothetically Kirby just eats every
Kirby's kind of a villain right he just
eats everything that's in front he is
like the concept of entropy
could be if if Kirby used its powers for
evil I would say so
yeah is Kirby mail I don't it is is
there a it's just a ball it's the blob
yeah if I dated Kirby would there be
like
would that be a weird Thanksgiving or
like how's that uh
I mean I'd be down I'd be down
so it's not really getting my likeness
in this okay what model are you using
mine
okay Mission refresh what
sure I hit that uh uh guy let me uh let
me bring up my model I'll start making
some of and
um
let's put
and I uh as you can see I have way too
many models I've trained a bunch of
people we know
um and uh there is now kind of an active
dream Booth uh checkpoint community of
people making models out there it's all
in the description down below uh but uh
there is
um
there's a whole Market of of people
making these cool you know custom
versions of stable diffusion uh it is
again a bit complicated and Jake but if
you're willing to put up with it man if
you're willing to push through it is
radical I'm gonna put Jan and lo Sada
fighting a dragon with a uh uh a shield
and sword B and B
fantasy art
digital art one of my favorite prompts
award-winning who gave me that award who
gave me that award I did
um uh at DND fantasy all right digital
art award-winning uh I'm gonna avoid uh
Greg we're at the retakowski again just
for this feed let's go Sans artist yeah
yeah
um fighting a dragon oh that's amazing
kitten Mage it it worked
like there's
some good ones let me see when they say
it came up with a magic card oh crazy
straight up and I saw I saw for a
textual uh uh inversion embedding
there's one that's just magic cards
that's awesome
um which [ __ ] yeah okay so look at that
I typed in uh Janam lasada fighting a
dragon with the shield and sword DMD
fantasy our digital art award-winning
epic stunning my negative prompts which
I've borrowed from another very good AI
artist a man named Joe Penna or you
might know him as Mr Guitar Man very
good friend of
everyone who meets them all right so
um uh in negative problems I have new
disfigured bad art deformed poorly drawn
extra limbs strange colors because
remember stable diffusion was made in
the UK uh blurry Bland boring sketch
lackluster repetitive cropped ugly and
what it's given me is some pretty fine
chance that's a gin uh you can't see the
dragon he's off frame I guess I'm
fighting this Dragon uh yeah just not I
don't think I'm aware he's there
all right so this is Jan fighting dragon
Jam of the for control of
a saver or something
um and then just you know kind of a
photo
like this like look at that hand oh you
can't really see it in my uh but yeah
there's a hand creeping up on that uh
uh yeah
look at that hand where's that guy
coming from
so let me let me you keep keep doing
your thing I'm gonna talk about
something of course so if you let's try
that let's let's start from the top down
all right we're in text to image we got
our our prompts here we negative prompts
we can type them if you want sampling
steps if I take this to zero I'm gonna
just make one image at a time by
adjusting the batch count that's just
booty noise that's just some noise
um oh oh my goodness Melanie
wow it has been a long time thank you
for that Super Chat and I know I missed
some super chats at the very beginning
I'll shout you out right now actually so
Melanie thank you so you say funny how
you're worried about
demonization when Jan has the f word in
the background
[Laughter]
ah uh that is actually a neon sign I
made I actually built that guy
um yeah so that's that's not only the f
word that's a art effort see that's art
that's art that's art right there
she says just kidding happy to see you
too on a stream hoping you're doing well
and please give kisses to Gilbert and
Teddy you know Teddy's chilling he's
sleeping here we got Gilbert he's
probably in the room in the back room
thank you Melanie so much good to see
you
um who else we missed some chats at the
very very beginning and I'm trying to
scroll up
to the beginning and I don't I don't see
them but my goodness apologies to you
um you know who you are thank you for
the support you guys I really appreciate
you
um back to it here so the sampling steps
if I take it to one it's just noise I
take it to two it's probably gonna be
some weird
shapes and colors that don't make any
sense take it to three and we start to
get that kitten Mage casting a spell on
a tree I can see a tree I can see some
sort of thing here a subject
you take those sample steps up more
it's going to take a little bit longer
right four five
um that's so cool wow it's like a
children's coloring book
yeah and what what's happening here is
kind of like with mid-journey where it
it goes through uh several steps of uh
pulling into latent space that's why
when you go to a sampling step of one it
looks like gaussian noise that is the
way the the latent space communicates
with with with noise
so I'm just like Oh Come slow it's Jan
and his brother fighting drag a dragon
that's pretty sweet dude that's awesome
so I mean uh I'm sure you want to get
back through sliders but I'm going to
mention a kind of problem with a lot of
a IR especially stable diffusion cloning
right if you look at all these images
you see that there are two jams often in
these images so what's happening can I
negative prompt for it negative prop
clone duplicate stuff like that you know
you could throw it in uh and it might
work chances are it won't because of the
way uh these models uh were trained at
least uh version four
um uh which is what I trained uh this
model off of it's not it's not a trained
off a version five but it all uh uh uh
latent space inside of stable diffusion
was trained off of 512 by 512 squares
right so when you go back and look at
all the the images the billions of
images that it was trained on they're
all five twelve by 512 and so when you
on your width and height slider when you
start to go away from that 512 think
about it like the computer is thinking
about it there are now two squares here
right in this image there's this square
right and this Square
and what has happened it has given a g m
lasada here and again I'm the loss out
of here because that's just the way it's
sort of uh uh uh communicating with
itself and with you so uh shout out to
Papa so he had a really good idea so he
said keep like change the seed so you
can see right above my head here I threw
seed count of one in here and that's
going to make sure it
it poops out the same image every time
right so now when I adjust the sampling
steps you guys can actually see what
it's doing to the image and like at
sample step seven it was like magic card
that it just straight up turned into a
magic card maybe here what I can do is
negative prompt Magic card
hmm
oh oh wow there's a photo of a cat in a
tree so it's not getting it's not
getting the Mage so let's like
let's put parentheses around mage
and what is a parenthetical doing there
so parenthetical is essentially doubling
down on that word and
it's it's just it's just like putting a
spotlight on that word and you can throw
multiple on it and right now it's not
changing it
even if I throw well maybe wizard how
about we put wizard instead of mage
in parentheses
oh that added a hole into the tree
that's so funny
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
good stuff Soto remove Magic from
all right we're getting closer and much
love much love all right
let's change the batch count to 10
because it's like okay and give it again
let it let it take uh some time yeah
yeah
because that way we're able to get an
assortment you get the Fun Pack you get
the the flight the sampler of
what you're going for and I wonder what
it's going to look like if the seed is
the same actually it's probably going to
be the same image 10 times
okay here's me fighting a half dragon
person this is getting close
what's your goal what are you working on
Jan
let me fire dragon
and I'm trying to avoid going to Mr
Rutkowski or any any other prompts
currently and uh yeah maybe uh some folk
in the feed I can't read it so the uh
Clint will have to help me out but um
maybe you can help me uh narrow this guy
down without uh just spamming it with
with artists I currently have epic
detailed painting Jan and Lozada
fighting a dragon with a shield and
sword d d fantasy our digital art
award-winning epic stunning wide shot
concept art Splash art uh 6K render
Masterpiece trending on Art station I
also have the exact same uh negative
prompts well what do you that I have
before what what don't you like about
what you're getting
ah it's just not quite uh like like I
really like this guy this looks like the
the you know a wraparound cover of a d d
book right I'm almost certain this
Dragon here was just more or less pulled
from a bunch of d d uh book covers so I
I would like a scene like this that is a
little more defined uh hopefully having
uh you know a clear single dragon and a
clear single fighter that looks as
dynamic as this well if you typically
what I would do as I'm making art for
artificial intelligent my the the area
that I sort of post my my AI art
um what I would do if I was really
hammering down I would change up your
sampling method really the the two Heavy
Hitters you'd be looking at is Euler a
Euler and ddim a lot of the models are
trained off of ddim so that that's just
sometimes very helpful I would hit
restore faces another big thing let's go
into settings let's go uh down to face
restoration there are a couple of
options down here where go with code
former there's a lot of reasons why we
go with code former we're just gonna do
it uh then hit apply settings up here
then we're going to go back into texted
image we're going to change our CFG
scales so the CFG scale or your
classifier free guidance scale is
essentially how much do you want the
program to be looking at your prompt so
if I put this up to let's say a healthy
15 and I hit generate let's give it the
20 seconds it's going to take
um this is usually where we bust out our
orbas a big big shout out to them and we
play a little music and then or or we we
play around with our butterfly knives or
maybe maybe you you have a drug habit
that you got to take care of I don't
know you do you then
it'll generate and it is getting uh
that's pretty good right we're getting
closer to a single Dragon a single Jan
in an epic fight so that's pretty sick
right uh there we have some duplicates
this is awesome that's rad I've got like
a sword Whip and I'm efficing fighting
two dragons two that's pretty good so
that's pretty sweet right uh there's a
couple more now let's just for fun take
this all the way down to one let's take
that CFG scale and let's see what it
does at one you're basically telling it
to have go nuts don't even look at my
prompt you don't even need words just
make some big beautiful art and yeah
look at that it has gone
pretty like if you want to see what
latent space kind of like this is the
art that stable diffusion wants to make
right this is Pure gaussian Noise just
being like like the the AI is sitting
there like this is beautiful and it
looks cool you don't know why you want
to mess it up with like form but this is
gorgeous so man yeah there's I've
actually had a lot of fun just playing
playing around in in the lower edges of
um
it's like a real just
loose watercolor you know very faint
yeah uh yeah and you can kind of I I
don't know maybe it's just me uh uh you
know this is a bit of a roar shark test
but I could see a little bit of dragon
in there right there's just a little
like just the way that the the lines are
moving I don't know maybe maybe I'm just
going nuts but that that looks a little
dragon-like dude look at this there's a
voxel art so I'm using a voxel art model
um dude sick which if you guys want
different like Styles and stuff if you
go to that Reddit Link in the
description there is like a uh they're
called checkpoints and they're like
different models or Styles there's a
library of that inside of that Reddit
link you can download all different
kinds of looks like uh
you know they have an Arcane one they
have a Borderlands one they have they
have a bunch they have like old Disney
they got new Disney so I'm on the voxel
art one right now uh and what a good
yeah yeah and and look you can all also
get voxel art from uh just prompting in
the main model you can also do that it
just won't be
uh voxel art represents a much smaller
part of latent space to the larger
models so it won't it won't be as like
fine-tuned if that makes any sense uh
whereas this is fine-tuned
there's also and we're unfortunately
this program is so deep that I I think
even if we had like three or four more
sessions we wouldn't really get through
all these tabs but there's also a way to
train uh what's considered an embedding
through textual immersion it's a lot
less
um in depth and it works uh pretty well
but not as well as a dream Booth trained
model will so embeddings can be made
under train here and you can go find a
ton of
independent tutorials in that that link
uh below there's uh my homie
artrepreneur
um uh I've never met him or or spoken to
him but we're homies because my God have
I he's on YouTube you know and I've
spent so much time with him
um so
let's let's do a challenge Jan
yeah let's do it uh do you want to show
people how to dream Booth or at least
get them
let's make versions of each other
of it I'm oh man I've been waiting yeah
me too oh man and then we'll show you
how to how to train the model which is
like a very it's technical you know you
might see some math on the screen or
something but uh and and there's a good
it's like a one out of four fail rate so
expect it to be a
in a year this is all going to be in an
app and you're just going to be able to
click through some predetermined windows
and it's going to be a joy and and super
super easy so I'm gonna show you real
quick I'm not gonna wait we're not gonna
wait I'm gonna show you guys real quick
once we're starting fresh top left here
we have our models I'm going to choose
the Jan model that he trained um I'm
gonna take the sampling steps to 30. I'm
gonna change the sampling method to ddim
right here
um batch count I'll probably hit 10
because I just want to like blast out a
bunch of different looks and see what
we're getting
um and then under settings I think we've
been here before but under settings face
restoration code former I'll check that
and then go ahead and apply the settings
uh back to the text to image tab
uh we're ready so Jen you gotta make
some cool character of me I'll make some
cool character of you I have a list here
well you know what okay hit me yeah sure
how about we take it to the chat let's
make this interactive what like what do
you guys want to see uh hit me with app
Punisher so I can see what the heck is
going on in the chat
um
what do you what version of me do you
want to see Jan create and what version
of Jan do you want to see me create
leave it in the
comments here and let me know
who like hit Clint as whatever or Jan as
whatever and that'll give us enough to
like to go off of
um Mitch how do I get the Dark theme so
I have some sort of yeah I I uh yeah I
went looking through I'm yeah anyway yes
yes
to be honest with you I don't know
because look if I make a new tab and I
hit Dark theme nothing's happening
um yeah it happens to everything else I
don't know how I
yeah dark mode Let's see I have it in
here somewhere oh well Google Docs dark
mode
maybe it's just some dark mode
um I also set
Google that's just so that's just a
photo of you with your hand on your
shoulder look
look good
now nothing like the product I adapt for
but you grew a [ __ ] weird hand dude
you grew up Oddball hand all right so
look at me handsome boy look like that's
a boy
oh Jen I'll leave it to you to pull what
you want of me from the comments and I'm
gonna pull
some something of you for the comments
how can I see that in comments are you
if you pull up the live stream
you can see
I'm doing that one
that's a good one
Rousseau says Jan as an 1880s weight
lifter I can imagine it it might not
only see that yeah it could totally do
that yeah this is gonna be it better see
um great this is gonna be great hold on
where
uh
sorry I was a schmuck and didn't even
put up the Stream
all right Jan M losada lifting weights
from the 1800s in the way in the 1800s
from the we'll find out let's generate
it
squirrel candy no we are keeping this
safe for work
I already like you I already like you
scroll candy you're you're you and I are
on the same page let's let's start
adding genitals to our faces all right
all right this is what this is what Jan
does on the side right you know this is
this is when this is when the stream
isn't running like you never know what
you're gonna get
yeah dude I will say be careful uh
because sometimes leighton's face just
comes at you
okay I gotta do like at a bodybuilding
show or something like
ooh clinches Mr Freeze you know what I'm
gonna go with that one
um oh I'm also trying to give you bark
skin but it's not quite working
it's adding you with a bunch of bark
like
music
yeah exactly
maybe I'll add that
all right so you're doing me as Mr
Freeze Mr Freeze I also
um I might try to uh because I picked up
a model that was comic book themed so
this might be a perfect
um time to show people how checkpoint
merger works
oh I mean
can I uh first of all Rad but can I add
a can can uh uh I had maybe a something
that might help but make it look a
little more old-timey yeah I mean yeah I
literally put an old-timey and sepia
tone in there sure I would try an old
type of Photography such as daggerio
type or wet plate photography and I
would put that at the very beginning
like a wet plate photo of Jan I would
then also put a year years are really
good years are really good for for train
or uh for prompting so I do 1800s I
should probably put 18 like late
yeah exactly 1895 or something yeah yeah
and you got you have to say it using an
old-timey voice right oh absolutely
I'll start digging into that soon uh
let's go with uh
Cole which x e i o man
as Mr Freeze
um from PC Comics books
hyper detailed
um
it's a hyper detail I am going to this
is going to be the first
um uh uh artist name I'm gonna use but
just because I love me my Alex Ross so
uh bye Alex Ross if you do not know his
comic book art it's incredible and I
would highly recommend it
you know what I'm gonna change that I'm
gonna make like a a tall tall version of
him next
okay okay see how adding see how now
we're starting to get uh some some black
and white photos dude dude I'm looking
swole I'm looking that's great this one
is awesome an old uh let's see
wet plate photo is it gonna know that
more than like film photography old film
sure I think wet plate uh uh you know
it's all about it's all about uh pulling
from those those parts of latent space
so try doing try just bombing it with
with uh like look at that wet plate yeah
it uh that that looks like a wet plate
photo uh now it lost some of the
bodybuilder oh I took that out I'm
trying to start basic yeah sure we've
got we've got our first results of U.S
Mr Freeze let's take a look I mean
that's just you as a pretty dope
superhero in a pretty sick City that
chick
wow
dude it's basically hush right this is
uh Bruce Clint and then the mysterious
other billionaire kid uh what was hush's
real name I I forget we're starting to
get I mean these are all great
um one thing all AI art has a lot of
trouble with uh uh is the uh word uh
right right just basic text and that's
there I've read a lot of varying
research papers on why that is
it really depends on who you want to who
you want to look at and believe but it's
a text just holds so much meaning uh
that that it's hard there will be like a
point where text will work inside of AI
art but it'll probably be done through a
different uh a different entirely this
is a great man look at this that's get
that's almost Mr Freeze right I'm in the
bathroom on the left yeah you're you're
hanging out there
um so
yeah I mean I I I I would probably bring
this into in painting and then you know
just take out the little head on your
shoulder maybe take out this guy and you
would be like it's Commandos right
that's that's pretty sick
I still want to see a good Mr Freeze
though I hadn't seen it oh I know I have
not seen it
what hit me hit me look look at the
stream
look at look at the Discord screen share
oh my God okay yeah I lost it somewhere
along I'm coming back
oh yes yes
[Laughter]
oh man that's only one that's only one
there's so much oh my god dude
oh my God
you're my great Granddad was [ __ ]
ripped
yes
yes
dude you look like a freaking jacked
kangaroo
oh my God
oh
it's Ross let's try that out let's try
that out let's uh change it up all right
I I'm a little sad that I don't have
tattoos but [ __ ] man oh my danger when
my gains are looking that good I don't
need tatters
I'm gonna try it I've tattooed
foreign
how many T's are in tattooed three
uh t-a-t-t-o uh there's two o's right
think do I not know how to spell tattoo
it's not tattooed right no it's uh uh
t-a-t-t-o-o yeah
thank you now of course uh the guy
living in Barcelona that's gonna correct
the summer no he's good which makes
sense no it makes sense I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay I mean this is you was like
this is you as Bruce freeze
oh that's neat that's actually you know
if I if I cut that off there that's
looking neat
oh my goodness dude
look it look at this
this is absurd I love that it's like a
black and white photo like
this thing existed a long time ago yeah
dude that's incredible
that looks like a photo from the world's
fair right like you would read about
bodybuilding and uh strong band at the
World's Fair
what's what's your prompt oh what
happened we're good we're good we're
good let's go to pull everything up
again
now my prompt is
I'm proud of it I'm proud of it hold on
oh a wet plate
photo of a tattooed Jan emlo Sada at a
bodybuilding competition in the year
1897 with parentheses around a wet plate
photo and bodybuilding okay
oh two two good
uh whoever's prompt that was congrats we
got it moving on yeah that's incredible
incredible I'm working on this here yeah
you keep doing your thing um in the chat
throw me another Jam let's do another
Jam please
and then we'll get into how this is how
this gets set up
Rousseau yes thank you dude thank you
let's get more uh let's get more ideas
for Jan here what do you want to see Jan
as
[Laughter]
oh
Jan as the Joker okay it's not bad
pirate Jan
we're starting to get
I at least caught you bald
right like it's almost there easy that's
like that this is like right before the
horrible accident right and you your
wife is still alive you're like a great
researcher you're you're Char admin oh
no he becomes Mr Freeze
um all right oh okay I mean getting
close getting close Janice Santa is not
bad
Jan is The Terminator that's not bad
again in The Matrix
oh you know what I actually have a few
of those already queued up
I never did anything with them but uh
hold up hold up
um
so there's a matrix Jan Oh that's what's
really interesting about that photo is I
have a bones cooked into my ear oh no
way uh because because so many of the
the rappers
sure enhance
oh no oh no
oh you look you look like uh oh wow yeah
so like my a lot of my ears get uh get
just jacked oh this one's actually
pretty sweet as far as Matrix Jans go
who
okay I could totally hear that one now
that's good I think I got my next gen
it's from chronic 667 Jan as a 1990s
action figure still in the box
okay okay okay okay okay
let's do it let's do it let's do it all
right those are all getting super close
uh let me
and scoop
and you know what I might uh
what else do you want to see with Clint
I feel like we've been on uh
um
uh what's it called a good old good old
Mr Freeze for a little too long
and I roughly got it what else do we
want
Jan as an orthodox uh Saint that's good
it's good Christian bookstore Jan um
lasered off tattooed Christian bookstore
again that's a personal favorite of mine
dude what else we got for Clint give me
some hit me something good Clint is Tony
Stark driving a Lamborghini okay Clint
is a Scooby-Doo villain oh I uh that
might be the winner yeah
Clint has a Scooby-Doo film let's try
that 400 pound we actually tried this
yesterday I wanted to I wanted to be
like I wanted to see what obese me
looked like but we did not set it at the
buffet but that's up to you Jan it's up
to you you're doing you're doing me I'm
doing you we're gonna figure this one
out
foreign
making some art I am thrilled uh frankly
if you want to uh tag in and you start
doing yourself I'll start doing uh yeah
let's get through another round of uh
sure sure animation cell uh
all right that's close
like we're we have action figure Jan
pretty quick out the gates that looks
like Bill Burr on the right that's funny
um
but it's not getting the original
packaging oh my God damn yeah
I can't wait to become a fashion
designer and sell shirts that just have
holes in the chest
okay animations
oh wow that's pretty good it's like
you're on an Oreo box
oh here we go top right we're starting
to get a little bit of the packaging
yeah maybe put clam shell or like you
know still uh an original package
[Laughter]
all right we need the packaging
um
let's try that out and I might uh come
back and uh bring down our CFG slider
scale
remember to knock around but remember to
occasionally like knock around your
sliders a little sure
um uh especially when you like you kind
of key generated uh similar images it
never hurts also if if you find yourself
just stuck or bored or whatever
what's happening with these uh well I've
we'll get into all that in a moment
what's up with all these little buttons
up here uh so the one at the top is
pretty funny uh some of you of um uh you
know this might be a controversial
button but you click this button and
it's just going to add an artist's name
uh and you could literally click this
button
like eight times oh crazy it just and it
just adds in random artists uh so that
you know if you find yourself in a
corner or you you you're not happy with
the style and you just want to uh add in
a little bit of uh extra flare you can
hit that button uh under it there's a
check mark uh which uh uh
uh uh it it'll add uh regeneration
parameters for the last uh prompt put it
in there's a uh uh some cool
applications for that you could save
your Styles and then if you found
something you're very very very happy
with like a a prompter combination of
prompts you can save that style and then
access them under here if you want to
add them to your business later
uh Saturday morning cartoon see you're
not a villain oh that's great wow that's
yeah but you're not villainous there
unless you're doing something to that
kid we don't want to know about
now this is all too you're looking a
little too happy that's pretty solid but
that's literally too wow that's insane
let me
let me hammer down on villain
and let me put in a date uh when was
Scooby-Doo was that 1970s I mean it's
it's still running I think so like
I got pretty close on this this
Packaging
this toy version of you
who did Scooby-Doo I don't know Chad who
did Scooby-Doo evil villain I'll try
that out I'll try evil villain and maybe
a uh yeah some parentheticals around
that that's pretty good
hey thank you thank you it's a Hannah
Barbara cartoon so we're
uh the random brain cells in my physical
latent space and my my biological latent
space sometimes work
um Matt Walker I know you said to
create me as a creepy ventriloquist doll
but I'm gonna do that to Jan next okay
I'm gonna try to get you as a ventril
queen okay I can
hear
and you
you need a villain like
Lottery right like this
this would like you know back here's the
Joker over here is like you know uh
Solomon Grundy and yeah yeah
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
this picture
wow it's like my new line of action
figures
the original wow it's a shirt it's an
action figure of you wearing your own
shirt
sick oh Scooby-Doo
evil villain uh High lady pale the uh
1970s anime
character I did that uh not not that
that is but a good idea but uh I did
that uh uh a few days ago two clinical
results
um
how do you spell ventriloquist
let's find out
oh this is the best yeah I can just do
this for hours right now we're hours and
hours and hours on end
guys look at all these
all these like you know uh tabs and
there's a whole
set of uh uh uh extensions you can add
on which you do did the list Grew From
Yesterday really dang what what got
added
oh man I'm gonna have to do a little bit
of reading on the GitHub after this I
will say almost all the extensions crash
my system to the point of
um disrepair so use them at your own
risk
okay I mean you're kind of a villain
there oh
man uh
mouth under your mouth and yeah again
it's a little bit of a rogue Gallery
like yeah I definitely see um what's his
name
the guy the the the the the oh they're
all white the the main the main dude
with like uh the white like Ascot what's
his name
we got
Freddy Freddy yeah
oh this is so much fun all right
while I'm letting that go
what uh oh then I thought you'd put me
with kids but no it's ventriloquist yeah
I'm trying to double down on the
ventriloquist
sure
there's a real creepy one I'm not gonna
open it up
unless it's coming out of me like quato
it's fun
we're losing the thread of the plot here
yeah it's hard to even tell oh
I could see a Clinton there we're still
getting a big old Road oh my gosh
disturbing this is literally you
this is puppet you and your real wife
with your fake puppet child
oh
hit me hit me I mean it's look at the
Discord go back to our disc gosh I keep
I keep buttsing oh my goodness
so so here's an interesting uh thing
when um when you're when you're working
with dream Booth you basically uh you're
unfreezing the model uh uh uh stable
diffusion cooked this model for however
long and then they froze it hand it to
you and you to dump it into your
automatic 11 11 and it works like a
charm and when you use dream Booth
you're unfreezing the model and putting
in 15 to 20 to 30 to uh I think Nico
last night was experimenting with 1600
right or 160 uh I forget the exactly
okay yeah you're putting a bunch of
yourself into the model and you're
basically ruining that model like I
wouldn't use this Clint model for oh man
okay so this is
I still don't really see you as a
villain but that's still pretty good
like splash screen of you
um so yeah yeah
uh so every man uh we basically I
basically replaced
uh all men in the model or anyone
anything that was in the man latency
it has now been affected by the issue
images of Clint I uploaded to it so now
all women all men all people in the
model have some version of Clint's
likeness added to it so this is why
sometimes you will see yourself uh like
as we're going through sometimes there's
a a another person next to Clint that
looks
very similar to Clint sometimes it's
female sometimes uh uh um you know
something in between uh and that that's
just something to consider that each the
second you make your personalized model
that model is not very good for much
else outside of you know making making
your friends laugh uh let me try let me
go back to
let's see what else we got with Janice
Kratos ah that would yeah that's that's
good
um I could I could see that Clint as
Gumby Universe claymation yeah let's
make let's make a Gumby Clint
let's do I'm gonna try and get a muppet
you and then you do gum wait you said
you're doing Gumby or what which one
zombie claymation yeah
um and then let's show people how to get
this set up of course easy way first
hard way second a second sure uh by easy
way
are you talking the built-in extension
or okay sure
I'm having trouble getting you to be a
puppet like it keeps having a bunch of
like other use in the shot yeah so
puppets are tough uh what I found works
well uh
um add in the term Muppets
okay at start adding in texture uh uh
things you know the type of puppet you
want
um another
uh another Avenue you might want to
start crying is uh starting to hammer in
with parentheticals and uh raising that
CFG scale okay
um I mean that's a pretty good puppet at
me uh you might just have to you know
edit out a little bit of a jam there
um how do I do like you like what's the
what's the text for like you as a puppet
do I say Janam Lozada as a puppet or do
I say puppet Jam
version you might want to just drop both
words in because remember this isn't you
might be reading it as a person you try
to read it like a computer would right
so the more you hit the word puppet in
there the more it's going to wait uh uh
that into latent space right uh the more
as it's trying to build the image the
more puppet words or hits you put in
there the more it's going to be like
fine I'll keep dragging these pixels out
of the puppet part of light and space
and dump them in there
um
uh it keeps like
getting you in here it's not puppet use
you with random puppets let's see
so start to mess around with your CFG
scale start to mess around with um uh
perhaps your sampler uh might uh might
might change things I would start really
throwing around those um parentheticals
and starting to get that uh
and and you know guys there's no like
wrong way to do this so if you find
yourself putting literally like 10
parentheticals around a word to get the
model to respond guess what
you're doing it right because as long as
the model responded as long as it showed
you more or less what you're looking for
good you did it uh here's you as a
Nintendo character with a mutated foot
um I'm in pain okay here's you hanging
out with your Creations
as a famous
celebration there it is not quite there
[Laughter]
wait hold on actually I want to do that
now like I want this genius
it's too good
too good hold on so I don't think it's a
registered claymation so I'm gonna do
two parentheticals on claymation I'm
also going to add
uh made
uh
made of
clay as a claymation character Gumby
texture animation ultra realistic
um let's let's start to spam the system
a little we'll put in 6K Unreal Engine
um render
uh oh sure let's let's start there
so yeah what uh what what these little
qualifiers at the end is just kind of um
adding in adding in some uh some weight
to areas of latent space that are
generally considered like typically
photos that are logged with uh of the
text of like Unreal Engine or render or
6K usually have characteristics that we
tend to associate with realistic looking
stuff so you can add that stuff at the
end uh to help weight the model toward
something good and then you end up with
claymation uh Clint here which is pretty
pretty fantastic pretty pretty good I'd
say that's uh yeah knocked out of the
park there what's up what's your prompt
okay The Prompt right now is
parentheticals around uh uh uh the the
token word
um that sort of active model it's click
the uh xcio man made of clay as a
claymation to parentheticals around
inclination character Gumby texture
animation ultra realistic 6K Unreal
Engine render
and yeah we got some pretty killer
results out oh
[Laughter]
that's good that's real good dude your
beard look like your beard looks like I
could touch it like I can't wait to feel
it across your fingertips
yeah those are all great
um
having trouble with the Muppet side of
things I'm trying to like okay
let me let me switch over to Muppet and
let's see if we can get you as a actual
puppet so I'm going to
yeah let me see a oh bad oh oh man
um made of felt
because felt I'm pretty sure most
Muppets are made of some form of felt
yeah
um that's a good prompt that's already
better than what I was doing a puppet of
Janam Lozada made of felt
as a muppet
character and then I'm going to take
away Gumby I'm going to leave in the
term texture I find when you're when
you're trying to do uh stuff that uh uh
isn't a digital painting or whatever
when you're trying to do uh when you're
trying to add texture in the word
texture just sometimes helps
every time I look over the extreme
oh my God for your birthday I'm gonna
make you one of these dude
so already you're getting great results
there right uh it's already working a
bit better yeah yeah it's the wording
it's like so you can get better at this
oh my god dude yeah I guess I guess too
you know
it's kind of like all all different
types of art uh uh uh just because it
looks easy doesn't mean you know there's
a skill tree for everything right so
there are some people who probably uh
blow me out of the water right get a
bang and prompt first uh first prom out
the gate I just have a decent processor
uh I'm uh a linked to so I just uh you
know bomb the server bomb the system I
mean that that's you
if I met this I'd be like oh if I walked
away from a day of working and was like
oh Clint I totally met you as a puppet
but it's not enough it's not enough of
you as a puppet so I'm gonna raise the
CFG scale a little and typically uh for
those of you that love your slider
numbers I typically sit between the
default seven and at most 15. uh 12 or
11 is usually a golden number
um so a puppet uh I'm gonna also add one
more parenthetical around Clint
dude you could do I I should take that
to the dentist like my teeth have never
looked that good
that's so good you know what next next
round I might lose a parenthetical
around Muppet
and uh
there's also a couple of really cool
tools uh one of them's in the extensions
and I had it working for a while until
it uh until crashed my system again all
of this is very experimental guys get
used to get used to going on GitHub get
used to asking for help
both a very good sales to have
um so one of the cool
um
uh uh things you can look at is the the
tokenizer and uh uh
God where is I believe it's the
tokenizer here uh the tokenizer will
will show you uh you'll put in your
prompt and then it will show you how
much weight each word has so as let's
say you really want to to get you have a
certain image you really want to to make
it through 100 AI generated art without
using any of the other tools in this
program uh you can check your weights
and then go back and start to look at it
uh uh with fresh eyes right
um uh there are a ton of tools to be
able to
go back
that's pretty good you go back one more
that dude
just just you doing a puppets artist
react that's what we're seeing right now
is puppet artist rehab oh my puppeteers
react oh too good
um so yeah let's dump let's let's let's
pause right now and of course let's walk
you guys through how to get this set up
so Jan do you want to walk through the
built-in version and then I'll walk
through the other the other version
okay does that work for you of course uh
just be aware the uh uh uh at a certain
point it's probably gonna crash on my
end because I've I've had uh I've had
two successful runs of this and four
full crashes to the point that I had to
restart the whole system so is there a
way for you to walk through it without
like actually doing it so that you don't
crash your system
let's I would love that let's give a
shot all right so let's let's let's give
it a shot my friend so first things
first
I'm going to go back to just one of my
proof I'm gonna go full screen on you
you good okay great of course
all right so we're gonna walk through
how to get your likeness into stable
diffusion uh to with by with two methods
all right Jan's gonna walk us through
the first method this is a bit more of a
streamlined like built-in version and
then I'll walk you through the other
method that is hair pulling but we'll
we'll get there I mean I'm I'm gonna
tell you right now they're both a little
hair pulling and there's a whole method
called textual inversion under the train
command here
um first and foremost make sure
everything you have is up to date if you
have the up-to-date uh 11 11 it will be
under train there's a ton of tutorials
on this we're not going to cover
training textual version I believe as do
most the internet that dream Booth is a
much more uh optimized version for uh uh
uh capturing your essence your likeness
also the homie Joe Penna uh sort of uh
uh spear Frontier good dream Booth we
love Joe so we're going to do that for
him and also a guy named uh uh this true
dream of training is based on a guy
named Shivam uh sharrow as a repo and
good on him it has lower uh vram uh than
the one I've been using that is a little
more successful so we're gonna navigate
to extensions we're gonna navigate away
from installed to available we're just
gonna hit load from that's going to load
from the github's automatica 111 uh um
uh uh directory and there's going to be
all sorts of bits and tools and you
could do what I did and install them all
and then watch your system
or we can go at one at a time because
already automatic 11 11 is pretty good
we're going to come down we're going to
navigate to for me it's Fourth Down
dream Booth we're going to move over to
install we're going to click install and
it's going to be doing some business and
then once uh the install area on the
right is uh down to a sort of grayed out
and it says installed we're going to
come up we're going to go back to text
to image we're going to refresh and
there's not going to be any difference
so we're going to restart get used to
restarting my friends it is so much fun
um so that's uh we're gonna open this up
I'm gonna come back find up my stable
diffusion uh um folder I'm going to go
back to a web UI slash user.bat I'm
going to double click that I'm going to
close this old guy because that's going
to get real confusing uh and now we can
see the the systems loading and going
through everything again I usually like
to have this guy hanging out to the side
so that
as things uh don't work the way you want
to you can at least see it happen in
real time and perhaps try to write down
or take take some note as to what is
happening so right now it's going
through the same basic process it
already went through
um it's uh loading and installing a
bunch of uh uh yeah all the requirements
for the UI
ah
so yeah that's uh gonna
continue to load uh your dream Booth
should be up to date if you run into a
problem where it is telling you that
dream Booth is not up to date go back to
your web UI slash user.bat right click
on it
go up to edits
that'll bring up a notepad and if you
see under uh uh under your set command
line uh underscore uh args equals type
in git git
space pull
p-u-l-l and this is essentially just a
telling uh the the web UI Dash user.pat
to update uh everything every time you
you launch it so I'm just going to close
that out I'm a little worried that this
is taking so long so I'm just going to
close that and we're going to go one
more time
so so far you inside of the web UI you
went to extensions
and you let me switch over
you went to extensions you went to
available
uh you load from you went to dream Booth
you installed dream booth and you went
back to install it apply and restart UI
and then when you reboot you should have
the dream Booth tab at the top is that
correct that is correct you know I might
have missed the apply and uh restart
yeah you're right I did miss that step
now I'm just reloading
um uh
uh yeah you know what you're yeah you
got me
um yes I might have to actually apply
and restart it uh uh from there my
apologies that's fine that's fine my
apologies
but after that
that so there's a video on this I I
think it's linked in the description it
may not be linked in the description but
I'll get it in there if it's not it's by
a guy AI entrepreneur and it's his like
second most recent video
um and it's walking you through this
process dream Booth built into stable
diffusion
um
and
it's a short video short process it lets
you train your models inside of
Dreamboat inside of uh stable diffusion
and
that it makes it easy it makes it it
makes it pretty easy
um far far and Far easier on your
processor
um so yeah that's just it's it's very
handy that it's now all inside of
automatic 1111 but once again
experimental uh all systems aren't built
equally so yeah you know you'll you'll
probably find yourself at uh at times
struggling you get it functioning so
we're gonna go over to dream Booth we're
going to click on dream Booth uh welcome
to another uh another set of confusion
so
uh the first thing we're going to need
to do is create a model this is sort of
a null object or an empty model that we
will be placing our Dream Booth
information inside of so I'm going to uh
call this uh Clint
big butt because I am just going to
train an entire model on Clint's face
and big butts and hopefully uh it merges
us into a beautiful thing uh so next I'm
going to come down to Source checkpoint
now this is uh uh where you know this is
where you could probably get funky and
start to train on top of other trained
models and start to get real deep into
that but we're not going to go there
we're going to start off by just
training on uh uh one of your stable
diffusion 1.5 models right I'm gonna go
on pruned uh V 1-5 pruned uh uh imanly
e-monolly it's a little less vram
intensive so maybe maybe I'll be able to
get it done by the end of the Stream
should everything work uh there are
several schedulers
um and if you want to know what a lot of
these terms mean there's a guy named the
computer file who just dumped a lot of
this is like a medium version of a
tutorial he's got like expert you wanna
you wanna know exactly what code is
let's get into it so I would keep it at
ddim as we mentioned earlier in our text
image tab there's a ddim is typically
what these models are made with so now
that we have all of that I'm going to
click create and we're gonna wait
there's going to be uh there's a little
bit of a glitch happening on my screen
there's two load bars uh I think that
should only be one but there's two
things loading simultaneously I don't
know so that goes for a while is that
the case and then it spits out a file
it actually doesn't go for that long
it'll go for 30 seconds I don't know how
long that was 15. uh and it's going to
tell you right up here created working
directory for Clint big butt at a d uh
end of our uh so you have now your model
so I'm going to cut them up here to the
upper left hand corner where it says
models I'm going to click and lo and
behold there's Clint big butt so I'm
going to click on Clint big butt now
there's another
um uh tab here uh under the dreambooth
tab and that tab might have been grayed
out before that's because you didn't
have a model available or selected now
that we have our Clint to big butt we
can go over to train model and whoa look
at all this there's a lot of a lot of
nonsense happening
um let's take it one step at a time uh
the concept list at the very top unless
you have a j s o n file that you want to
throw in
um
don't mess with that if you know what a
Json file is let a brother know
um
next we're going to go to uh instance
prompt now this is the prompt that you
want to try uh for because I kind of
have to show you a real uh Clint big
butts more of a joke than uh anything
I'm just going to uh train off of
the regularization images I have for uh
screw it uh uh I've got my friend Ren
here A friend of the the cast friend of
the stream friend of everything so uh uh
I have some uh training images with uh
uh our our lovely homie Wren so we're
gonna take these uh training images and
we're going to put them into uh the uh
automatic 11 11's
um uh uh uh Matrix right so I'm going to
open that up I'm going to copy come up
to uh the clipboard here copy the uh uh
file trajectory the the uh file path
um
oh I'm so sorry we were on prompts I am
so sorry I am getting uh getting you to
be confused so we're going to try and
the math is Flowing dude it's uh we're
we're going to train you uh we're going
to uh train this on my friend Ren right
so I am going to an instance prompt I am
going to tell it what it is training uh
what it's going to be training off of
and that is a photo of Ren and I'm going
to add something so that the the term
Ren doesn't doesn't be get recognized by
latent space as being a different brand
you know there's a lot of Wrens out
there uh I know it's it's troubling and
terrible but there are and we don't want
our friend Ren to be uh infected by by
any of the others so I'm just going to
add uh a why and the y r uh yeah
uh that's a pretty weird word I'd out
that's going to be anywhere uh in the
model affected and then I'm going to
follow it with the class prompt that
we're going to be replacing for me I
have already in my uh Library I have a
regularization images I have
regularization images of woman
skateboard man and Appliance uh I'm I I
could probably also use person there's a
lot of ways of getting regularization
images that that's basically you telling
the model
what you will be replacing we're going
to replace the word man with the word
Ren y r right so I'm going to hit man at
the end of that a photo of Ren y r man
then under class prompt I'm going to
ignore these two uh check boxes go down
to class prompt I'm going to hit a
photo of
man or a man uh let's just do a man
um
and yeah all of this is kind of an
experiment anyway so you can you can
play around with it see what gives you
better results uh then pretend uh vae
name or path that is for a vae model
that you already have we don't have that
so
uh uh we are going to do the data set
directory up here this is a path to your
input images again these are the images
that we will be using to uh infect the
model with rent we Ren isn't
acknowledged by the model so I am just
going to uh copy his path and you want
to show what the images are like just
show an example of what the image looks
like and like
sure I would love to yeah you want a
collection of uh here I have your images
I think ready
to go
screw it uh so
this will be ways and then the
so these are all photos of Ren
mostly pulled off the interwebs it is
almost all close-ups
uh with a few wide angles uh to sort of
get body positioning uh and stuff like
that down we have for Renault here 25
images selected right notice they're all
the same size
yes so you uh uh right
yes uh and it really textual inversion
allows you to train off of different
sized images but we'll get that that's
for a different day yes you because
stable diffusion was trained off of 512
by 512 images you also want your images
to be at least squares uh Nico actually
I believe trains uh off of Just Square
images they don't need he's trained off
of non 512 by 512 squares I find I get
better results with 512 by 5 12. so yeah
so uh anywhere from uh 20 to 30 roughly
rough-ish photos should do the trick uh
just to start out right so then the
classification data set directory uh is
the the the data set that you're going
to be retraining right so I have dream
booth regularization in uh um images man
1500 so I'm going to copy that I am
going to pay place that directory right
there
so if you guys don't realize by this
point how deep all this stuff is
oh it's a it's a lot it is a lot and um
you know that's one reason why we want
to do this stream is to help you guys
get to this point and I know even if two
of you
get to this point like then that's
that's a success
um we did yeah we did a great job great
job yeah yeah
um and there are other there are other
videos going over this stuff if you guys
need help
um again it's linked in the description
but Jen I'll let you okay yeah
if you find yourself lost at any point
yep welcome to
uh to anyone that says air it's real
easy just show them this um well welcome
to air we'll um we'll be we'll be we'll
be struggling the whole way so training
steps training steps is determined off
of the amount of uh photos you're
bringing in the amount uh you are
altering uh uh the amount of your your
original photos and the regularization
images it's also uh linked to a lot of
math inside of the model we're going to
go with it's anywhere between 1100 and
1200 images is pretty good you can go up
to 1500 uh you you could hypothetically
train it
ten thousand steps but you're gonna find
your your images starting to look like a
deep fried meme right they're going to
be overcooked and without seeing a
deep-fried meme right let's describe it
to deep-fried meme it's a contrasty uh
oversaturated oh all the stuff that kind
of leads to the images
um
so I'm actually not uh entirely sure
about the number of classification
images to use I would imagine they're
the same I imagine uh uh um because if
you don't put anything in the
classification data set directory it
will produce
a number of images that I believe you
put into this uh um this area so you if
you didn't have regularization images to
give it you would just hit 1500 and it
would use the uh your your processor to
First make the regularization images and
then uh train your your model well uh
question question what what what other
things need to be changed here because
most of this can be left as default
correct so like maybe just touch on like
the stuff that we need to change and
yeah of course and I'm trying to also
add contacts and explanations things but
that might just be further confusing it
so I might just uh uh I see the math has
been going on my face for a while so
perhaps we'll just give you some blanket
uh blanket instructions here we're going
to turn our learning rate down their two
schools of thought here either more
training steps lower learning rate or
higher learning rate lower training
steps play around with these guys look
online the dream Booth Discord has a lot
of different uh formulas or recipes you
can try your resolution of the images uh
look at that 512 all of the resolution
of my images are 512. there are bulk
cropping and bulk image setting uh
websites that uh you can visit
actually fun these are uh your
checkpoints these are saved along the
way to show you your progress as you're
training your model I have heard from
our homie entrepreneur uh that our AI
entrepreneur it's a hard work to say
um I've heard from him that this these
are kind of broken right now they're
kind of fun to look at so once when they
do get fixed we'll we'll probably add
these back but for right now let's put
them both at uh you know three thousand
or five thousand or whatever uh so that
they never actually get put them over
the amount of training steps so they
they never actually get engaged right uh
then we're gonna come down preview image
all of that is great uh and you'll see
that the sampling steps are at 40 the uh
uh your your uh CFG scale is that 7.5
all seems pretty standard we're going to
drop open our advanced
um
if you're like yeah I'm real poor and
don't have a good computer there's a lot
of other methods for you you can go to
Virtual servers like uh collab or
um a run pod or what have you uh
you can click this little button and use
CPU only this is truly I'm gonna go to
sleep
I'm just going to hit train I'm going to
go to sleep and I hope to God when I
wake up this is working uh we uh uh uh
we have a decent processor now so we're
not going to do that we're going to use
8-bit atom this is a way to reduce your
vram uh if you just want to flex and
use a lot of vram go nuts
uh and lastly we're going to uh do our
mixed Precision down to fp6 to beam
everything else you can leave standard
and alone
all right moment of truth
we're gonna come on up
and I'm going to hit train now once
again I have my command screen open
uh because dealing with any sort of
coding there's always a moment you hold
your breath when you hit this and we can
see vram's cleared we can see some
business is happening and it's come down
to steps and it is hanging out at zero
percent so right now
it for all intents and purposes is
working and at this point
uh this would start to run and uh if
everything if your computer's uh doing
doing its best it would start to run and
you would start to oh you would start to
see some progress
um now I'm going to bring this out I
believe Clint's heads behind it but in
the code here you could see after the
bug report and it's done all sorts of uh
uh language here telling you that it's
looted all the stuff you can now see
steps four percent and a bar that's
going across the screen at this point we
are working it is functional and uh it
has run this is now four I I I'm almost
at a 50 success rate this is three
successes out of seven runs so yeah uh
and and uh this actually used to not be
the case you used to have to just assume
how long it was going to take it's
telling us it's going to take 10 minutes
uh to get process access this so
literally by the time the the stream is
done we will have a brand new checkpoint
of our good friend Ren to play around
with
so good job I can't believe uh yeah
again this is a lot this had a and it
had a it has a high failure rate so I'm
I'm really glad I didn't embarrass
myself in front of the internet I'm so
glad internet that you can think to
yourself Jay it's a cool guy and he
knows what he's talking about all right
great we will come back and we'll see if
yeah that's working
um let me so that's that's that's one
way to do it to get it built in
to your web UI of stable diffusion
that's how you're going to train a model
on a person in this web UI and even if
it does crash on you
chances are it's easier to just start
from the ground up again
and get everything functional again or
troubleshooting through this method the
old version of Joe penna's dream Booth
though it is very reliable if you
thought that was confusing wait till we
dive into this Clint take it away all
right so like Jan said I'd probably go
with that method and I'd probably run
that method and it'll crash on you but
just keep trying it yeah and chances are
you'll you'll find the uh yeah you'll
find do you know the minimum vram amount
for what you just set up
oh I you know and I don't I know it's
tiny compared to what it used to be it
might be 12 gigs or 24. that's not tiny
though
yeah oh I mean tiny compared to uh
running running dreambooth through Joe
Pena's is 48 to 64 gigs of vram I mean
when it first came out we we were just
going on to like digital servers like
run pod uh uh getting an ace an a100 and
then just paying for like a week's worth
of just holding on to that that
processor because of that uh uh um
uh an a6000 or an a100 and a100 is even
better I think uh 64. yeah it's 64 gigs
of uh processing power it's uh yeah
you're you need a lot of vram I believe
with the 8-Bit fix it brings it down to
12 gigs of vram at the very most 24.
neither I mean it's still pretty
intensive
um at the end of the day you can still
do a virtual machine and there is a link
in the description to a tutorial it's a
40 minute tutorial but it shows you
exactly how to do kind of what I'm gonna
get into right now so I'm gonna give you
guys the overview of another method
um if this method does not work for you
then try this all right
let's see here
so
um
all right what you want to do is I
believe this is linked in the
description Google
um
dream booth
Joe Penna GitHub
the latest one uh takes eight gigs of
vram so pretty substantially smaller
than um than it used to be yeah yeah
just keep trying I know one of you said
that you kind of like petered out give
it a shot see how it goes
um so you're gonna You're Gonna Wanna
grab uh grab the dream booth
Joe Penna GitHub link right this is on
Google it's this readme.md it's also in
that Reddit link if you scroll down and
find that all right you click the green
code you download the zip and you got a
dream Booth folder I'm just gonna do
this with you guys
I'll do it on the side just so that I
can uh I can play along I'm playing
along Clint
all right so we got dream Booth we're
gonna right click it we'll extract it oh
I already have it all right and it's
hidden somewhere give me a second
where the heck is it
it's somewhere
oh where'd you drop a dream what's it in
the G drive I remember you would put it
in G G uh root it's just on my C I
deleted it okay okay okay okay great
great so extract this
dream Booth we'll open it up and you
will look be looking at some
some files here again these are files
that did not make any sense to me a few
days ago yeah
um I think first things first
we are going to open up Anaconda
can't believe we're doing this on the
stream this is insane uh yeah dude uh I
hope at home you're listening to Matrix
music and I hope uh yeah uh follow the
White Rabbit my friends follow the white
rabbit so
all right
before we hop into this we need to
determine a couple things let's open up
this environment.yaml file I'm going to
open it with notepad all right
um open with notepad and we'll see the
name ldm I'm going to change this to
dream Booth V5 because that's what I'm
on at this point you can change it to
dreambooth V1 if you want but just know
that that's what we're going to be
searching for in Anaconda all right so
we'll we'll save that out and inside of
anaconda which is another program you
need to download it is in the
description we're gonna we're gonna get
to this C drive dream Booth folder I'm
also going to just
rename the stream Booth folder to dream
Booth B5 so we have to type a whole
bunch of stuff
and we'll do let's see CB films I want
to go
desktop oh geez I'm gonna make this easy
I'm gonna go to my G drive I'm gonna
drop this into my G Drive
make it easier on us let's go g colon so
now we're into that and let's do a seat
we'll type CD space that folder
dreambooth V5 now we're in there all
right
so from this point we need to build the
environment what the heck does that mean
I you know I'm not going to try and
pretend
if Nico is here you could explain it
yeah you're you're creating a place that
you can uh launch programs from it's uh
yeah
all right so basically let me get this
out of here
all right
so we're in this folder inside of
anaconda all right and what I'm gonna do
is Jan do you know it's in our Discord
chat history it's like
conda
active environment oh and and uh EnV
yeah build
what is it Dash f
environment Dot yaml yep all right so
it's conda space EnV space build space
Dash f space environment.yaml we're
looking to this file right here
environment dot yeah well that's the one
where we changed the name to dreambooth
V5 I'm going to hit enter and see what
happens this might not work
hmm
I
um
I swear I swear there's a a step or two
missing in there unfortunately uh dream
Booth didn't work invalid Choice build
it's not built can you look at our chat
history Jan what is it I am staring at
it right now uh let us see here it's a
it's a copy paste from Anaconda it's a
screen grab so you should be able to see
it pretty quickly it's like a black and
white image
sure there's a few of them floating on
here um three eight I think yeah and
conda and envy create uh space Dash f
space environment
y-a-m-l got it got it I'm gonna
type that in here uh that's going to be
conda EMV create Dash f
environment dot Gamel
so it's doing its thing it's downloading
a bunch of stuff and you can I think
this folder is being filled with with
stuff as we speak so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to fill this
folder up with some things that we'll
need to train the image off of very
similar to what Jan was talking about
with having training images I'm gonna
have my 25 training images here they're
all square resolution of my face some
wider body shots Etc most of them should
be clear shots of your face different
lighting conditions different
backgrounds help different clothing uh
different Expressions you know yeah give
it a variety good variety yeah
um
so we have that folder it's called Clint
images I'm gonna drag that into the root
folder of my my dream Booth V5 folder
um
also the regularization
um images here are just all a bunch of
images of a man and these are
1644 images of a man that's kind of what
it's like looking to to build a man
and no that's what that's that's the key
for that so I'm going to drop that in
here that's you can look that up online
it's look up you know dream Booth
regularization images and it'll you'll
have a folder with like
some for men some for women uh et cetera
et cetera so both of those are in here
um the last thing I'll drop in is models
so in the models folder
I'm gonna just drop the standard model
you can drop that 1.5 model in here as
well the one that we downloaded at the
beginning of the stream once again
the Link's in the description it's on
that Reddit link as well with the
resources um the Reddit resources page
will take you to the models uh the
models Library so from there
we have the the three big files that we
need dropped into our folder and here in
Anaconda we just got a complete retrieve
nose is working done we we did it okay
amazing yeah yeah amazing great great so
far so good I can't believe this is
going so well
um
so from here there's a few
little surgery tweaks we need to make to
some of these files in the Stream Booth
folder in order to kind of trick it to
replace images of a man's face with
images of my face so we need to tell it
where to look because remember we
dropped in those two folders
so let's start from the top I believe
it's configs we need to hop into configs
we need to hop into the stable diffusion
folder and we need to open up the fine
tune unfrozen yaml folder this is deep
y'all let me put the math on I don't
know what
we got the mask no this is you're you're
on point though this is great this is
great so this is just a bunch of
internal computer guts here and we have
to change a few things so
if I scroll down to the data hold on
here we go if I scroll down to the point
where I see data reg and validation
that's what we're looking at here data
reg and validation
um let me switch to
oh I don't have split screen top this
will work though
great
um so data
this is looking the repeats at the very
bottom of this data chain here we have
100 set to um repeat set to 100. we want
to change this to
136 and that is because I'll show you
how to get how I'm getting this number I
have 22 images of my face all right
um we are going to train this what's the
right word three thousand times three
thousand iterations three thousand yeah
they'll be they'll be three thousand
steps uh uh steps along the way yeah you
can see that at the very bottom of the
of the screen here 3000 Max steps so
what we're going to do is take the
calculator out and we're going to say 3
000 divided by 22 images of me we get
136. that's how I'm getting that repeats
underneath look at that quick math quick
maths
now for these for reg and validation
this is looking at the regularization
images there are
1644 regularization images of a generic
man so I'm going to do that 3000 steps
divided by 1644 which gets us 1.8 so
I'll just round it up to two shout outs
to Nico he really helped me out with
this yesterday oh I mean until 1am yeah
yeah
um so repeats but it takes two but it
takes a community my friends uh instead
of uh a Nico you have Discord so yeah
I'm sure with the power of all your
friends we can we can do this yeah so
reg repeat set to two validation repeat
set to do close this out save it all
right save and close
we're done with that let's back out
let's back out we're gonna hit up the
ldm folder next and we're going to go
into good good good data we're gonna
open up personalized py in Notebook this
is um this isn't mandatory
but
a good little tip here
from our boy Nico this little flip this
flip right here set to 0.5 and I believe
what it's doing is it's just mirroring
your face
but if you have you know all of our
faces are asymmetrical and to get a true
likeness you can set that flip to zero
right I'm going to leave it as is for
now because who knows what's going to
explode but mess with that all right
you're gonna get credit we're going to
crash a lot but you can set that to zero
if you want all right
um next what is next Let's see we got
our environment yaml oh the the the
the boot thing
yeah oh we have a token name that stuff
okay so can you Jen can you um
can you just I believe the token name
actually changed uh uh uh spots it used
to be in um ldm uh uh uh uh ldm under
the um the folder you were just in I
believe it changed over to
now it's just in the Run come on command
that's what it seemed like with Nico
last night yeah yeah I believe it got
changed over to the Run command I'm a
little out of my depths uh for the new
version of uh the new old version of
dream Booth so let me uh of course
Discord again
and real quick uh if you want to jump
over to my screen just for a second yeah
yeah let me hop over to you
too so while we're looking up I can uh
show the results because we already
we're already done
training it through automatic 11 11. how
sick is that if you look at the code it
did a bunch of stuff look at all that
stuff it did did a bunch of stuff and
all that stuff being great
uh uh it left us on the screen and it
said model done and then if I come up
here and click on stable diffusion
checkpoint
in there I'm gonna find Clint big butt
clip big butt underscore 1200 that's the
uh steps that were in there uh so it
automatically lets you know and again
very important as you experiment it's
very important to keep track of all this
uh I I uh uh good prompting technique is
to have an open document file or an open
drive file on uh your window or perhaps
on a second Monitor and just as you go
along save the code slap it in there the
Lord knows when you'll need it it's a
lot of that anyway
so now I'm going to come over
to text to image and I already did it
but I put in a
w-r-e-n-y-r I hit generate
and boom if I squinted and was like is
someone's brother there oh my God is
that Red's brother dude that's Ren as
like a freaking rotten pumpkin
oh wow yeah so we're starting to see
some aspects of red
um I think I need to change uh some of
my settings a little uh but we're
starting to we're starting to get get a
little bit of rain in there right uh I'm
seeing that
um what people uh I'm not sure if I
believe this part but a lot of folks
smarter than me uh uh say it
they they say to really activate the
model you also add the
um the regularization word that you
replaced so wire man and supposedly
you'll get better results
now sure is better sure why not I'm not
sure if adding the regularization word
is helping it's kind of like the the
term trending on Art station is that
actually helping your image I don't know
but they say it does and smarter people
and I are usually smarter than I am so
there you go
but yes here's to show you that the
dream Booth inside of automatic 1111
works it does work
that's huge like that yep that's the
easiest way to do it is is yes and the
and the lease processor intensive it's
it's great it's great it's great
all right so I'm right at the end here
I'm gonna grab the it's essentially like
the go key it's the the command the
final magic words to say to Anaconda to
start your training here in dreambooth
so let me give me two seconds here
um
all right all right all right let me
switch back
so what I have here is
let's see I'm gonna make a text file and
this is just to like
keep our stuff uh organized it's not
going to reference this at all
um
you know boot boot phrase I don't know
we can call it that I'm gonna hop in
here I'm gonna paste this file and this
is something
personally I don't know where people
grab this
um
it's a little bit when you're working in
Anaconda you're you're you'll run
commands are
it's a little bit just instinctual like
you you pretty much run everything in a
a similar fashion at the same time if
you go on to uh uh AI entrepreneurs uh
Discord or you uh uh go around that sort
of list of uh training material
um on that Reddit link you'll you'll
you'll be able to find varying commands
like this
all right so I'm just working this right
now to make sure
um I have everything in order so after
this n it's clintonius that's what I
want my keyword to be
um
data root data root reg images man 1644
is that correct
so I'm looking at yeah I I got some
notes from yesterday
um the data root space uh so uh dash
dash reg underscore data underscore root
space red capital I because uh uh I
would just assume that uh the cases
matter uh reg images man 1644 space yeah
and then the token dash dash token
clintonius yep where I'm confused is
this spot here let me actually
let me re-pace this
so it's
I'm having trouble seeing your yeah so
it's Dash and clintonius right
uh dash dash I believe I believe well
that's what that's what Nico had in his
so okay clintonius dash gpus dash dash
data root training images oh that was
Clint images Clint images so this is
this is very confusing but basically you
want to replace all this stuff with like
the folder names that you have so this
first one after dash n is going to be
yes absolutely the the the the the image
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um your your the images that you'll be
using to influence the model into
putting uh Clint's face in there yeah
the 22 images you're pointing uh
Anaconda to uh uh the area that 20
charges are so after this dash n that's
the keyword so when I was looking up Jan
m m losada
um it that would be the same thing this
would be clintonius right and then we're
going to move down we're going to find
Clint images or this this will be where
you put
the same folder
that you have your training images in so
Clint images
same thing Clint images all right next
we'll keep going
uh
I'm replacing with Nico so root images
next we have here dash dash reg data
root regimages that's going to be our
regularization images so that's going to
be reg images man 1644 that's that
folder we dropped in
and then the token my token is going to
be clintonius
and the class word man yep yep yep
training steps so training steps we had
in that last folder was three thousand
Max training steps three thousand that's
what we're basing all this stuff off of
I'm gonna copy this
close this save this I'm gonna paste
this in here
no I'm gonna be honest with you I had
never gotten this to work
ever give it a shot
I'm gonna paste it and let's we were
literally working on all this until
maybe 15 minutes before the stream so
yep
it's a little bit of the blind leading
the blind right now but oh man we're
gonna make it through it's thinking and
it crashed okay so what was uh Pi torch
is it pie torch again it is pi torch I
hit my wall This is the End like if you
all made it this far to the 195 people
all the hats off to you this is as far
as I've made it that's why I wanted to
talk about both of these is because you
got Jan's method that's going to get you
built in he you sh he showed it work
just now okay this method it works like
a charm it does uh yeah this method is
more like sound it's more stable but
it's a lot more difficult to get going
um Jan's Jan's method that he showed you
a little bit before that it'll crash a
lot more currently it'll probably be
better next week yeah it'll probably be
better next week absolutely but
currently it is you know it's funny
stable diffusion it's not very stable
right it's like it's like yeah I know I
can uh and I'm not even a dad
um it it it's a lot like getting a game
in in Alpha right like it
you just can't rely uh I rarely will let
it just sit for a day or two just open
because chances are it'll just crash
itself for no good reason
um so stay fractalesque
um I see you in the chat you said why
don't you just throw a mid Journey back
to your Discord I did that we did it
this morning so hop in create some stuff
in mid-journey that's what I'm saying
like mid journey is paid it's it's
definitely it's incredible yeah yeah mid
journey is like you guys saw we spent
maybe 45 minutes in mid-journey just
having fun it's very it's simple
compared to this oh my God
and it has one of the uh one of the most
dynamic models in all of uh AI art it
It's banging version four frankly all
the versions since three have been
banging they're just so good
um it just you don't get you don't get
that massive amount of control and for a
person who likes to put a lot of gory
images together
it is uh uh yeah it's um it is
restricted uh in what you can mix so
yeah
um I hit my wall here you know like I'm
at an error pie torch this has been my
life you know I've been sleeping rolling
rolling around in bed just pie torch pie
torch we'll get to the bottom of it
we'll put uh I I imagine somewhere well
maybe even in text put what uh what'll
get past that point but yeah
I am yeah pretty beat I'm gonna be
honest like what a stream we've gone for
three hours
um
do you want to do like one last version
of each other to call it a day
we must we must uh what
I'm gonna do what do you want to do
uh should we reach out to the people of
the internet I mean they've been pretty
good at given us given us some uh some
prompts before
yeah let's do it let me open up stable
diffusion if you guys have any ideas for
what you want to see Jan or I as
let us know in the chat hit me with at
Punisher
um
and we're gonna do one last little round
here and and then I want a copy of all
those bodybuilding ones I want a copy
you guys
too good
yeah absolutely
and then we're gonna do and then I'll do
the weekly weekly challenge we'll let
Jane go and I'll do the weekly challenge
for y'all and uh maybe sit back and
enjoy some water or something
oh okay Jen this is how we have to end
it
us us together
oh okay great great great great great
um yeah let me show you uh that'll
require using another tab I'll try not
to get too into the weed today yeah just
guide me through as simple as possible
oh gosh of course we'll start off uh
with just a one five model so okay
let's get that guy loaded up
this is more or less the method I was
using to make uh some of those
um some of the the promotional material
for this this stream uh so we've got
uh uh uh we've got this wonderful
wonderful image of our friend uh oh boy
all right all right all right Ren's
gonna see images of this and he's like
what where are these coming from why
like they're gonna be coming from random
people and he's like who who I'm sorry
Ren no I'm not sorry Jan should be the
one apologize
I will never apologize to you right
never yeah
um much love my friend much love all
right let's uh let's start off in 1.5
okay
um so I've got 1.5 pruned
um same uh the the the sort of more vram
uh intensive one this is more meant for
like fine-tune work at the same time we
have the processors for it let's use it
all right I'm gonna prompt something uh
where where should we be
um
love it I love that okay let's rock
climb
I love it and I'm gonna leave it at 512
by 512 just to be able to avoid
duplications cloning all the all the
problems we kind of went over earlier
with uh um with this process so I'm
going to start off with a photo of two
men on a mountain
uh smiling uh let's put a couple little
qualifiers let's do a 50 millimeter lens
shallow depth of field and here's a fun
one a here's a little bit of prompt
engineering not a lot of people uh put
some thought into let's say I wanted a
full body photo of Ren but I just keep
getting these mutant [ __ ] faces of
them uh and I just I keep typing in full
body wide shot you know and it just the
computers just not working with me so
try to think like a computer
um so on top of shallow depth appeal uh
field right let's put really fancy shoes
so now not only is it going to try and
make two men on a mountain smiling so we
know that it'll be two people
with smiling faces we assume and then it
also is going to try to give them shoes
so now you're basically forcing the the
the the the the
uh AI to both get to give you those two
things thus giving you a wide shot let's
see how effective it was so it gave us
really fancy shoes
let's let's up our batch count real
quick uh uh let's try going through
those but uh if you yeah you're I love
it you're doing it you're actually doing
uh rock climbing on a wall I think I'm
just trying to get
up and I crashed
oh
yep I think uh I think you might have to
go on without me I'm gonna try to get
everything
um you want to guide me through of
course this this is a corridor challenge
blindfold me
um you got the Discord stream
oh I'm not no I'm just I'm aware I'm
just saying like you know
let me
Let Me Go full screen
ah that sucks it was working so well
until I tried to up the batch count oh
and it's a vram problem
okay
so let's say how to do like close up
uh so maybe maybe at the beginning put
portrait photograph yeah okay
portrait photo of two men you know uh uh
uh yeah try try attacking it uh the
problem now okay all right a portrait
photo of two rock climbers on the side
of a rock wall
let's generate that or side of a
mountain
it's so disappointing that crashed oh
right at the end too got it working
until right then
all right all right here we go here we
go
okay are you finding yeah that one to
the left there looks pretty good yeah
yeah
look at that guy
so that's a good starting point
um I'm gonna hit another one I'm gonna
just gonna hit another one and
let's do face restore faces you think
sure make sure that setting is um it's
under settings make sure code former
yeah there's some arguments to be made
for gfp Gan but uh the code former is
the way to go it has a chance seal of
approval
um great maybe add uh uh um in uh
negative prompts helmets it might be
easier to get her like this without okay
yeah without help so can I skip or
interrupt which you can interrupt
interrupt that'll just stop it right
there
helmet plural or Hell or both try helmet
helmets uh uh hat you know all that
business
oh
just refresh interrupt yeah I'd refresh
it hey oh what was the prompt uh a
photo a portrait
photo photo of two rock climbers on the
side of a rock wall
helmet we don't want helmets or helmet
and we want to put parentheses around
portrait photo to get a little closer
sure and we want to make sure we store
faces is checked ddim we'll go 30 sample
steps batch size 10 and generate
I am going to yoke so hard after this oh
eat
oh
when we're going climbing again when we
hit hopefully next week
okay
I'm leveraging our audience to force you
into getting out on them Peaks all right
see how effective negative prompting is
right uh that that took care of the
helmets no problem right uh look at
there's like there's like holds on the
rock wall that's hilarious
I I there's something about how
impossible that photo that is uh
incredible this one
yeah that's like like was it making
sense there
um of two
male rock climbers male
and maybe put like uh you know friends
Bros uh that that might help the the
positioning that they're in so yeah if
you find like it's looking a little too
coupley or whatever you know um uh think
about the uh think about
you know a lot of the a lot of the text
data sets were done by uh uh people that
were were logging this uh stuff or or
log this stuff for websites you know
think about what if if your job was to
forget images right like just put put a
text at the bottom a PNG information on
all these images you'd probably get real
uh uh lazy about sentence structure
right you'd probably start hitting you
know Angelina Jolie dark hair uh Dressed
uh background
um heels looking grumpy and then just on
to the next one right so you it it's
good to try to get into the mindset of
the people that were uh training the
training data you know
I love our extra arms there let me get
that out extra climbs dang it I mean
extra limbs
um
[Music]
and then
let's see
I'll do one more
okay
ah
hey guys son I really hope you all have
a ton of fun with AI art I hope it's
been it's a little less scary
than if you had no experience with it I
hope uh yeah this made it a little more
accessible
um
and that it it just becomes another tool
in your
in your your toolbox you know I almost
all my AI generated art that I share
also goes through a few other steps
right whether it's Photoshop Lightroom
uh often times topaz I like to use my
own upscalers I just
I think I I'm a little bitter that I
paid for them so I just don't want to
use some freebies out there I'm like no
damn it
I'm doing another batch doubling it
trying to get a little closer because
we're almost there we're almost there
yeah close close I see some Keepers in
there for sure
you know another another day of
reinforcing uh closer images like
bringing in the word selfie I know
um oftentimes it'll give you that arm up
but sometimes it just gives you the
selfie like size
uh uh frame yeah without like a raised
up arm you know
okay oh there's like two minutes
oh man
just some [ __ ] mutant babies
dude this guy's freaking yolk City geez
foreign
like this one
Maybe
or this one
oh
yeah that's good all right let's do this
one
great uh now at the bottom of that
screen you're going to see a few options
down there Save which uh
all of these images will pump out and
your output folders every single one but
the ones you save will go into your log
folder so you don't have to sift through
you know I'll I'll put out uh hundreds
of generations for for an idea and then
that way you don't have to sift through
it next you have a send to image to
image and send to inpate I wish we were
able to get into image damage today but
you know say lady uh over there they're
sent to inpate I'd click on that
okay
so now we've gone over to the image to
image tab but we are using a tab inside
of image image called in painting this
is probably going to be the most useful
tool there's a lot of uh online
applications like alpaca that are uh
Photoshop that are basically building
text generated
um uh uh brushes so yeah Clint has just
showed us that he has brushed out uh uh
the person on the left's face uh you're
now going to simplify that uh font
keeping the keeping what made it good
right all the stuff at the end
but the part of a photo portrait that
that still works or portrait photo that
still works what you want to take out is
of two men uh and replace that with the
token you want to use right so let's
let's say the one on the left is gonna
be oh me uh clintonius right great [ __ ]
uh good old Clint I believe uh um you
never got clintonius working it's uh
Clint
do I need to switch the model yes now
you would switch the models so we did
the first image using uh the 1.5 model
we've now sent it over we we we're happy
with an image we've sent it over to uh
image to image we've taken it into in
paint we've changed our model over to
the personalized models that we have
we've highlighted the face and now
we're going to uh um we're going to uh
probably up your batch count just
because uh you know it gets a little
wonky and we'll we might have to do a
little bit of business
um yeah down here you'll see a very
similar set of tools uh that you saw in
text uh to image think about it in the
same way so you want to restore faces
probably you probably want to use code
former it's pretty good uh I would also
change over to ddim just because you you
made your images in ddim uh the sampling
steps probably you know 30s 30s fine 20
is even fine uh and then uh we'll be
messing around that's GL I would put it
a little bit right now where is uh oh
there yeah CFG scales at the about 10. I
put it sure 10 10 is great and then uh
bringing up your batch count a little
bit let's start generating some stuff
all right bam generate
what's the face check box
restore face
um takes a bit more
more juice yes yes it does
I I will say though uh
we used to in the early days of AI art
we used to have to take it to an
entirely different uh you used to uh
take your messed up faces then go to the
the
um code former uh uh collab run it
through that individually one by one and
the world's just gotten so much easier
now so much easier so yeah I
I just kind of leave it on especially if
you're looking for faces how are those
guys doing not good I'm changing like a
prompt to a photo of my face essentially
okay great I would leave okay sure and I
would put some parentheticals in there
and I would leave uh some of those uh
back end like Photo did you do any
do you do any like uh 50 millimeter or
any any uh descriptive props
need to be that's uh sometimes this is
more than enough
oh man not looking good
not looking double double down on um uh
the Clint double down on some
parentheticals
so uh another uh another thing I've been
realizing and we're now getting really
if you if you thought we were talking in
baseball before
um
B
I think uh uh I think everyone needs
like two models I think you need a
close-up model and a wide shot model
right uh uh when you're training I
haven't done this yet this is what this
week will represent to me
um is training this Theory uh because
typically your faces get really
distorted in anything larger than a
medium shot what we in the film business
call a cowboy shot so anything more than
a cowboy shot and you the faces start to
really go uh South so I think if you
train a model entirely on wide shots
um and and and you know just anything
full body I think it would really help
for situations like this this is brutal
yeah it's not working it's not working
for me I I mean I I hate to say this is
where uh I just kind of keep hammering
it down it took me uh that that image of
us holding that plaque took me about two
hours yesterday wow I think I went
through at least two or three hundred
iterations of both of our faces yeah it
yeah uh uh I honestly at a certain point
just photoshopping it would probably be
easier but to be able to say this was
100 AI generated is a cool thing cool
thing
I love how this guy is just on the right
is not even hanging on to the wall nope
Ed confidence man confidence
also no rope system to speak of
whatsoever
free clemming with my buddy in in our uh
Reeboks
yeah it's like it's having a tough time
sure I'd uh how many parentheticals you
got around your name freaking three
uh go five
really hammered it
should I change the prompt
or just yeah uh for sure like a photo
face for sure face yeah just that sure
that out
again this is really hammering down why
I think why I think two different models
are necessary because it knocks
close-ups out of the park they're saying
um or at least it can in paint at Full
Resolution I'm gonna check that next
sure
oh yeah God sorry I wasn't even looking
at the uh there there are a couple other
ways of combating
um yeah combating the the problem we're
we're using so sorry after after my
program crashed I kind of gave up yes uh
the internet's saying they're saying
make sure to upscale the image two times
so what how what would be the best way
to do that
I am so sorry
width and height
oh oh okay sure to uh add sure yeah I'd
uh and uh uh yeah bring those uh bring
those sliders up yeah for sure let's
give that a shot
much slower
slower you basically just triple yeah
tripled up the uh the work it was doing
yeah and then
hypothetically uh training in latent
space it actually generates him did it
just crash or did you just change oh
sorry sorry uh uh it's working with 64
by 64 images and then it upscales them
up to 512.
um uh so
yeah yeah
I love that we're finally in the aid the
day and age where you can enhance photos
where like resolution doesn't really
matter
um between all the upscalers out there
and um uh uh topaz or just
right
yeah I guess it depends on like what uh
what your final how you're finally
viewing and I think a lot of stuff is
viewed from phones
so it's I think it'd be a lot more of a
thing if it was viewed from a screen
you know
a TV
theater
I think
just depends on how you're viewing it
I'd say
yeah but I mean if you looked at that uh
documentary that um Peter Jackson did
the Beatles documentary I mean all that
footage was garbage right it was like a
bunch of super 16 that's been sitting
around and often eight mil that's been
sitting around and
uh uh being being left unattended for
ages and he was able to clean it up and
get it on my TV and sure if uh if you
have a trained eye it's definitely
distracting at times but you know my mom
didn't mention once uh uh uh that a
negative image quality right most people
are just going to look at it and be like
sick
yeah it's all it comes down to the story
and the content of what you're looking
at versus the pixel like if you're
looking at like a low resolution
you know then you're probably missing
everything else
oh it's like how some of the best video
games of all time I still don't think
Jack 2's Graphics have ever been outdone
and yet if I ever go back and look at
Jack 2 it's hard to look at right but my
brain at the time went this is amazing
look at this world incredible what a
great game yeah Jack two I think that's
where my love of one wheel started
oh really because the motorbike yeah and
he has a a board right you uh you bust
out a board for parts of that I swear
yeah it's like a shield surf kind of
thing yeah but like uh um a little
better than cheese yeah it's like an
actual hover hovering yeah hold on
I might have to call it pretty soon here
I'm uh yeah for sure and I mean listen
Nana uh arrt wow it's it turned me into
some geometric
that's terrifying
I can't wait I can't wait I'm sorry I'm
on the Rock screen no it's not good it's
the CFG skills
okay uh just okay is it uh it's
overcooked like curtain
but it gets burnt yeah for sure
what uh what was your CFG scale 15. okay
which isn't crazy I would also yeah for
sure I would also drop your uh well 15's
actually starting to get up there but uh
I also drop your
um your your batch count like just do a
couple of images uh if just for scream's
sake you know I took the resolution back
down let's see if this does anything
okay
wow I look like a freaking Smash Bros
character
that's
yeah cool
yeah and then we'd start to uh zero in
try to combat that do um uh do more in
painting like once you have a face that
more or less Works
um you can then go in and paint stuff
out honestly uh Photoshop has a real
bitching built-in thing called content
aware fill once you've once you've
knocked it around uh in pain for long
enough content to wear Phil is very
great tool you can use
um
the the other thing is thinking about
your mask size that sometimes having it
larger or smaller will help narrow in a
stable diffusion and let it know where
where in the space to sort of put you I
noticed for myself I always give it a
little extra room for my pointy beard
um my Beard's really not that pointy and
you can kind of see it but in in AI art
it becomes like you know
I turn into Gandalf with a pointy beard
oh
wow is that what the normal guy looked
like jeez
I think
um yeah what uh what what else uh does
your does your uh uh uh
uh your your interest in air what what
else can you see this being used as like
in your workflow I know you had
mentioned bringing it in as a concept
art which uh sorry all those concept
artists in the world but uh yeah that's
a great great way of uh implementing
concept art right well I mean I agreed
yeah I me personally I use the concept
art more is just reference imagery so
I'm I'm using it as uh
you know like
just stuff to build a mood board with
that kind of stuff um that's like my
main obvious first kind of go-to thing
um my second thing would be for textures
for creating textures I think that's
really exciting
um or for creating supplementary uh
things in your uh in your world so I
know that like uh some of the stress
level zero guys they were using it to
build like background posters for their
game it's just in the back you know but
it looks perfect yeah sure sure some of
the artists here on the Discord server
they would use it to create like they
created playing cards with it so there's
a lot of like fun little small things to
do I'm not I love creating and I will
always be creating
um and even doing the manual Hands-On
work to create it's just fun for me just
because a robot can do it doesn't mean
you have to do it and do do what's fun
for you do what's fun you know I know a
lot of you in the or a couple of you are
very adamant on this is you know how
could this be a thing this is horrible
this is immoral like we're losing all
this and that it's like well it's a very
like negative way to look at it I think
and yeah there are some issues but it's
new technology it's it's blowing up it's
gonna happen and we'll see where it goes
from there you know it's I'm interested
and curious about it myself
because I'm an artist
yeah oh I am and we're artists and uh
it's not like we're we're paint we're
not we're not like uh you know tradition
we're not we're not actors or you know
um uh uh uh uh we're not dealing with
actual pain we're we're cutting it like
we're digital artists right we we uh as
filmmakers as as as a digital artists we
should always be concerned and and up
with the times I I think it's it's yet
another tool it's yet another tool if
you thought uh if you think 3D modeling
is a cool art then yeah I I
it's hard for me to hold both those
things in my brain at the same time
um but you know we're not we're not here
to debate the ethics and morality I'm
here to bait every single person on the
face of the planet I will fight you all
Jan it has been an absolute pleasure to
have you here man uh thank you for
guiding me through all of this of course
I'm glad it mostly worked I'm glad
mostly worked I can't wait to like keep
diving in here and just have some cool
like versions of myself and like I can
test out different haircuts yeah I love
it yeah sure sure
um I can see what I look like with
tattoos you know
let's see what I look like as a
Christian bookstore owner
yeah and a full head of hair
um so Jan I'm Gonna Let You Go guys I'm
gonna I'll be right back of course I'm
gonna use the restroom much love
everyone of the internet you're all the
best I love you all uh godspeed thank
you Jan
I'll catch you guys soon I'll be back
for weekly weekly challenge don't miss
it I'll be back in like two minutes just
gonna use the restroom
keep your butts where they're at bye Jan
foreign
oh
man what a stream
that was a lot that was a lot of
infoblast into your brains
um thank you all for
for joining me for that Jan and I
um it's a crazy world crazy times
definitely definitely but I I hope that
you know we brought some value to you
guys I hope we give you a little bit of
an idea of where this is at we're
probably somewhere towards
we're not at the the top top top Cutting
Edge because that stuff is being
developed I mean what we're working on
right now is I'm constantly being
updated and developed
um it'll be better in a week from now
it'll be better in three days from now
so
um I I do hope that you guys can use
this as artists as opposed to you know
feeling scared by it I hope you can find
some value in this so
um with all of that out of the way it is
time
to pull up a chair because my goodness
my back I've been standing all that time
and go over
the weekly challenge uh retro futurism
is the theme let's hop over and see who
the winners are
let me get my ducks at row
all right
so
first up for the Retro futurism
weekly challenge we got five winners to
get into let me let me actually grab the
chat too I want to get the chat over
here I feel like I hadn't talked to you
guys in a long time
what's going on everybody
what's all this it's talking about the
chat here
how's everyone doing if you guys are
still with me let me get a little thumbs
up
and if you have any questions for me
please throw them down right now I'm
happy to answer them um we'll do the
weekly challenge I'll answer a few
questions and stuff
while you guys do that I am gonna get
started so
first up first winner of the Retro
futurism challenge we got James jarby
coming in with this very disturbing
image and this is a artistic take on
another
um
artists work from France in the 1800s I
think uh based off my brief description
of what James posted on Discord was it
they were challenged with
imagining a few what the future would
look like
um in the year 2000 or something and
it's just the darkest view possible
um and James did his take on that and
yeah that's I mean dude that's dark as
dark as it gets but
um it's it's great it says a lot
um you did a really good job with the
style I love that kind of like it looks
realistic but you have the like cell
shaded look on it that Borderlands kind
of look on it uh you did a really nice
job modeling the entire room the desks
and everything
um
the book machine and whatnot
uh and your lighting is solid it's just
a solid scene so congratulations James
Darby 15 points to you if you guys want
to participate in the weekly challenges
the Discord is down below we do them
every single week
um next up we got
our John Malcolm here
dude I would love a short film like this
your render quality is Top Notch that
background you have is insane I don't
know if that's I would assume it's just
an image
from like NASA or something I don't
think you you're rendering stuff down
there
who knows but you do have like a little
volumetric cloud in the foreground which
is nice
um your volumetric smoke Trails coming
out the back are insane your texture and
materials are absurd
um the model itself is really cool this
is a Loosely based on um an old image
from who knows when and where but
um
you really took a lot of nice creative
liberties with it and you made this
Giant
spaceship blimp thing
your own you made it really really cool
and your lighting is absurd your
materials are absurd so congratulations
John Malcolm for crushing it this week
you did a really good job
next up who do we got uh this one is
called retrofuturistic render challenge
scene Cinema render final instance
or Aroma Rome law
um name your dang
images as your Discord name please it
makes it easier for us makes it easier
for
um yeah we don't have to track down your
your Discord name this one's awesome I
love your colors here and your render
Style
that I mean and honestly
your your theme is really really cool I
kind of got to look at it for a little
bit to really
take it all in because I feel like
there's a there's almost a lack of depth
in this and you really have to study the
image to see what's going on of course
on the bottom you know we have normal
life on the top we have Robo World on
the left we got the robo hand the right
we got the human I just really love your
render style your colors are so cool
like if I just
squint my eyes and look at that I was
like almost like just like a mosaic or
something I love I just love your colors
I love your style I love the way you're
doing it and it's a really cool
interpretation of
you know futuristic kind of world done
in a very simple render style I dig it a
lot
who's next
we got awesome BL we got a lot of people
doing these like magazine covers and
stuff
but you did the best in my mind
um One is because of your uh your your
like type face your type font and your
design the way you're laying the text
out on the actual magazine a lot of the
other ones they didn't look professional
yours looks pretty darn professional to
me
um the thick text combined with the
skinny text you have a few different
um fonts in here so it makes it feel
full I really dig that I love your
colors I also love the fact first off
your framing is perfect
like the two cars are perfectly sat
there perfectly framed
um the the sunlight the way the Shadow
from the background cuts off right at
the top of the cars is perfect and even
the shadow on the left side of frame of
the car is just popping out the car's
like crazy your color is so nice that
red that blue that yellow very basic
colors but man you're crushing it and
you're really filling the space well
nothing feels empty and nothing feels
over packed the the close-up of that
wheel is a perfect addition I don't know
if that's something you added like last
but that close-up of the wheel brings it
all together if that wasn't there it
would feel
it could feel pretty empty
um and you have the crease in the piece
of paper that is huge I want to like
these are old
ads right of what a future would look
like
and to me having a super crisp and clean
ad doesn't really I don't know
I want to see it with imperfections and
you did a great job with that fold Mark
that crease down the middle
um hats off to you really good stuff
and finally we have under
with ah this beautiful layout again like
we're talking about these magazines and
these ads lots of people did them this
week
but look like it's not just the ad
you're including it in the background so
you have that real like I don't know
what kind of carpet you would call that
but I imagine it to be some carpet from
the 70s or something I don't know you
got the phone cord going you have the
old keyboard and whatever that is off to
the left but you can feel the old
technology in the era right I imagine it
to be 70s or I don't know 80s or
something and you put together a really
beautiful scene
um on an actual magazine so
hats off to you as well under you you
crushed it 15 points to all you guys you
got some really really good art this
week let's get into some honorable
mentions because you know it'd be a
crime to to just move on from here so
next we have who's next uh wondrous
so you took it a little like you took it
in a different direction and I commend
that for sure
um you got a robot
way down the depths
of a forgotten forgotten City and you
got a uh my soul airplane flying over I
dig it
um
I don't really know if I have any notes
or anything but
I like the idea it's very it's very
creepy actually
yeah I just want to shout you out good
stuff wondrous next up we have blender
man
you put together like a whole scene look
at this
um you said that steampunk is your
favorite retro futuristic style so you
were happy to dive into that look at
this man you got like this almost feels
like a point-and-click adventure game
um or or even just like a little
animated short film you got the Town
Square here the blimps the buildings
like you really did a solid job of
piecing this whole thing together and
making it feel coherent your lighting is
solid it has that sepia touch to it
which makes it feel old-timey I love
your cartoon characters you're you're
firing on all cylinders here
really really good work I think we're
coming up on the last image maybe that's
the first image
a little balloon boy happy birthday
so it's probably the kids birthday right
and he's got a little robot friend
that's great really really good stuff
solid work blender man
uh and the Creator himself
that's awesome all right next we have
hey it's what does that say
CDR
yeah I think that's what it says
um
you said this was from an image
um of a French artist
depicting a future some sort of
futuristic
scenario and I wonder if it's from that
same batch of French artists from the
1800s
um that uh James jarby was referencing
but I love the style it's so cool it
reminds me of a book I'm reading right
now uh the three body well technically
it's
the third book
it's either the second or the third I
think it's the second book book
uh Dark Forest I think from the three
body problem Trilogy and you have
characters who wake up from hibernation
200 years later into a futuristic
um futuristic world
and you have the character on the right
who would be like a hibernator right
they just woke up and they're trying to
grasp this new reality this new future
and everyone else is just accustomed to
it like this little kid
you know he's used to having the jet
pack
I love it I think it's a really cool art
style I would probably lower the
exposure Just a Touch personally Just a
Touch
um but who's next we got Jack the hack
uh you put together a nice little scene
here you got really nice color contrast
like the orange and the blue slash
purple
um I think that's yellow I am colorblind
but I'm pretty sure you got some like
yellow lanterns back there bright blue
light really cool car design
um you know solid at the filmic aspect
ratio 235 aspect ratio
um it's just a well-rendered scene it's
a well-lit scene so I want to shout you
out next is uh Nas or Naz this one came
close this was like my second favorite
ad
um I think the Texas 2013 on the bottom
left
doesn't feel like it fits
it it's it needs to be a little smaller
or something or have some sort of
you kind of lose it the X especially and
it kind of bleeds into the car just a
touch
um but I loved your colors and and you
really nailed that
futuristic look from the 60s or
something you know
so I wanted to shout you out good stuff
Nas
um next we have
retro futurism void 80.
um
this is just some good environment
design
some good like architectural design here
you did a solid job depicting what like
a like a gentleman's club or dance
clubs I don't know would look like
um
really clean render
you got the subtle depth of field in
there some subtle film grain in there
really cool colors
um and it's creepy because it's like
does anyone work here anymore I don't
see anybody there's a silhouette back
there but that's probably just like an
ad or something
but you really did a great job great job
designing this so I wanted to shout you
out
um we have sci-fi next okay this one
yo all right this one makes me feel the
most I think out of all of these this
just takes me back to
ah I don't know old old computer games
um it's your colors specifically your
colors your basic shapes
and
um there's like a filter over it that
makes it feel like
some upres something there's like a
sharpening thing on it it's not it's not
aliased
um so there's stepping and all of like
curved shapes very geometric
um I I really dig this one a lot like a
lot of you say oh this is so basic oh
you know like low effort but no I I
think this really captures a mood for me
you did a great job with the composition
too
um and I think second to last we have
SUNY
um dig your colors dig your presentation
reminds me of like an old acting book I
have it's like that same color the same
text
um and you did a nice job like piecing
together what a book would look like it
would be cool to have that on a coffee
table
on that coffee table that you modeled
for the front cover your scene I think
that would be cool but you did a good
job with like the colors the
presentation
um and it really it has a feel to it and
finally I just want to shout out is that
Yodi Davey
you know what that says yeah
um
really cool yeah really really cool like
portable home thing you got going on
here it's an advertisement the blue and
the gold stars that color contrast goes
nicely together
um I think you did a really good job
modeling it you did a good job lighting
it and presenting it uh it's it's pretty
simple pretty straightforward but it's
framed very nicely it's I would probably
have a little bit more Headroom on the
house
personally
the text up there feels a little
crunched
but
I mean other than that I'm a fan you
know it's it's good stuff very good
stuff and that
is it for the weekly challenge I think
um this month
I'll check it but I think the weekly
challenge this month is like cold or
something let me see y'all voted on it
uh earlier in the week let's see
um under weekly challenge weekly
challenge we got cold that's it yep
make a cold render we're getting into
that uh into that winter time Christmas
time is coming up so you guys will start
seeing some Christmas themed stuff
um
so
I'll take five ten minutes with you guys
it's been a minute since we've chatted
you know as as it happens when you get a
guest on
how is everybody
goodness gracious
diverse green it is AI stuff you just
hopped in at the end it's all AI stuff
we got some thumbs popoxo I'm glad that
you enjoyed the uh
the Stream
very very happy about that we got some
thumbs UPS in here
what's going on guys feel free to ask me
any questions you've got
are you all alive
stay fractalest we're looking at
retrofuturism for that weekly challenge
diverse green
uh did you get it running yourself did
you get dream Booth running yourself is
very difficult
a very heady
very tiring to get that stuff running
makes you just want to wait until it's
easy to do you know but once you get in
it's a good time
hypoxo yay I'm glad you enjoyed it um
you hadn't been participating in the
weeklies
because you've been doing a lot of 3D
printing you're trying to make a living
painting and selling figures crazy man
shoot that's awesome best of luck to you
um
yeah I would love to see some you should
post some of your stuff on the server
man
that's super cool
diverse green uh what is your I
tease I don't know what that means
you're you're it slash S your its on
training with your GPU and What GPU do I
use so my entire rig my computer is
linked in the description if you go to
the very bottom you can follow a link
it'll take you to puget's website I'm on
a Puget rig uh I have an a6000 in here
48 gigs of vram it's a ton
um but it makes
you know as 3D artists we're trying to
get the most juice as possible
um you can never be up to date
never
more has always been which is why it's
kind of expensive but y'all know you got
you guys make it work with with what you
got I think we all know that at this
point
um Liam do you need a specific python
install to get stable diffusion working
I got 311 but I'm gonna try a 2.10 so I
actually had everything working on my
computer I did some I did something
that caused my entire stable diffusion
set up to not work I woke up this
morning an hour before the stream and it
was not working so I actually had to
restore my computer to a previous like
Save State
to like 10 p.m last night when I
installed python 11. uh what is it
python 3.11
and I installed python the previous
version like 3.10 or something and it
worked I don't know if that was the
issue but
you know
um have I tried generating textures with
AI yet yes I have it's really cool we
did it at the beginning of the stream in
Med Journey it's very very fun it's just
so cool to experiment and explore what
you can do with this I think what we're
imagining what is possible with this is
only a fraction of what will actually be
possible in the future
it's like we can't even imagine what we
could do with all this
um but yeah textures are super cool I
hadn't really used them yet I hadn't
made the textures taken them made a
normal map made it a height map and used
it yet but
maybe I'll make a video on that I don't
know we'll see
oh Chris evolver yo what's up man
shout outs to you thank you so much for
the support always really really do
appreciate you man
um this is the first stream we've done
in in
it feels like a long time but it's a
month it's the first time I posted in a
month
um it's good to be back certainly I'm
working on some really cool videos I got
one coming out in a couple weeks from
now
um I'm gonna show you how to do like
speed environments it comes out the
Saturday
uh right after Thanksgiving
uh what day is that
let me find out for you guys I'll just
tell you tell you while we're here so
November 26th I have a video coming out
where I
um and create a speed environment in
Unreal Engine and it's photo real
um it's full of
of detail and everything and I'm using
my
my uh my trips my travels you know
photography from those times as
inspiration to almost kick start and
shortcut a personal style and that is
such a big thing for artists you really
want to develop your style that is you
in your art and using
photographs from just my phone my iPhone
they have to be crazy photographs
from trips I took that are special to me
it makes the art so personal to me so
not only are are you recreating that
personal memory
but you can do an artistic
interpretation on top of it so I show
you how to how to do that in literally a
day in uh in Unreal Engine it took me a
day to do I'll show you guys how to get
there as quick as possible so that'll be
a cool one it comes out
um two Saturdays from now
long story short Chris I appreciate you
thank you man
um am I planning on using AI with my
unreal workflows you know right now I've
only used it as concept art
with unreal um and technically on my
last piece I did
let me see if I can pull it up for you
guys
um
I did use AI generated images using
mid-journey
to
let me pull it up for you guys
just so I can I can show you exactly
what I'm talking about
dang they changed YouTube a little bit
all right here we go
so this video
here
right so if you look at this screen
at the end
let me get this guy out of here
this those images are created using
um mid-journey and they're like
ghibli-esque kind of
watercolory looking
Landscapes right so I used mid-journey
to create that
um
that probably other than that like
concept art too you know
um
so I'm just going down the list here if
you guys have any questions feel free to
ask hit me with at Punisher
be on here for a little bit more with
you guys
oh yeah there is a tiling button in
stable diffusion
so if I switch back here
and we do if we check tiling
I closed my uh
my python so I don't know if this will
still work but I can say like rock
texture and if you check tiling
it'll do its thing
so it's creating 20 different images of
a rock texture and if by checking the
tiling box
it'll make them seamless
metatrox am I going to make anything for
the kit bash 3D Minerva challenge I wish
it sounds like fun I'm just too busy
you know making videos
doing my own art making videos on the
art
um
but I got the kit it's a free kit if
y'all are looking for a free kit bash
kit go grab their Minerva kit
um I also have a link in the description
it is an affiliate link I get a little
Kickback if you guys are looking to get
some kid bash stuff then definitely go
check it out down in the description
um helps me out saves you 20 you guys
will always get 20 off of your kid bash
stuff by using my link in the
description so
you know definitely do that
um yeah so you can see it made some
seamless textures here
pretty nuts pretty nuts we can take away
some of this stuff we can say um no
grass
no green
no Moss
um and we can do like lava rock
texture
generate that and see what it does
um
so cake man all right you said you feel
like your personal style isn't something
you develop it just happens because
you're the one doing it kind of like
handwriting so I half agree half
disagree I think as artists we we follow
a lot of tutorials we're kind of copying
other people's art we're recreating
other people's art and
that's not you that's them right you're
following tutorials you're doing art
that's theirs and then you're you know
even going as far as saying I made this
we are we all did it you know I did it
when I was when I was uh first starting
out I'd follow tutorials and post my
progress I was really proud of but I
think the more you can kind of like
take what you're learning and
personalize it
um to your own kind of thing
that's just diving deeper into your own
style granted right if you're creating
stuff that you're inspired by the stuff
you're seeing out
um in the world and creating that then
yeah you got you got a style and I think
the more you create the more your style
will be developed people can just look
at that and be like oh you know that's a
that's a Clint piece or that's a
sodomonte piece or a pepoxo piece of art
foreign yeah look at this we got a bunch
of like really cool
lava rock textures oh this one's super
cool
wow this is awesome
it's like a wallpaper almost
lava rock
wallpaper
texture let's see what that what happens
then
yeah what about the pro the the prospect
of AI to create 3D models so you can do
a high variation of models that can be
then be bashed into one real
uh yeah well I mean text to 3D models
would be insane yeah if you just like
chair
um
you know Victorian house uh old wooden
table
it just gets us creating faster so
it'd be it'd be nuts it'd be absolutely
insane
well wallpaper image like
oh
interest oh this is cool
I like that a lot
this is pretty sweet
what about like
water
um blue and green water color
painting it will do abstract
swirl
um and we'll do no uh let's see let's do
texture
and I don't want any like
uh well let's see what it gives us let's
take this down as well
what do you think about using 2D images
to make its own bump map or for textures
um I mean it's kind of how you do it
like
I have a video on it's called
like create custom textures or something
or yeah create make your own custom
textures
and I go out and take a bunch of photos
of like
um a storm drain a really long tiled
image of a storm drain to make a very
specific texture and
I brought that into
Photoshop to stitch it together but I
also use Photoshop to create a normal
map and I'm not using bump Maps I just
use normal Maps
um so yeah I take the diffuse image or
the Albedo or the color image and I run
it through Photoshop generate it's like
filter 3D normal and you make a normal
map
and I think you can also make a depth
map in Photoshop as well I know there
are other programs like uh
substance
some like spin-off of substance
something I know you can do all that in
substance but like you can take a 2D
image throw it in and get all the stuff
back
I forget the name of it
I hadn't done it much
yeah this is crazy
here let me do oh I'm still okay blue
blue and green watercolor painting
of me let's do
of Clint
see yo man
let's see what that does watercolor
painting portrait
let's see what that gets us
oh so it's not all right so let's
uncheck tiling it's not getting me
let's do watercolor
let's do a watercolor
portrait
of me
color
portrait
and let's see
what that does
Ben ooh shout outs
to the keyboard okay all right look at
it
we got a
what is this G man it's been a minute
since I bought this
GM MK it's a gmmk pro keyboard
custom keycaps let's see get you the
upside down View
boom I got these like
Garden matcha Garden keys on them
it's got the hiragana Japanese like sub
caps
with I believe
tactile
switches what is it linear tactile yeah
tactile switches
shout outs man you appreciate
yeah investing in a custom nice keyboard
like mechanical keyboard oh makes
everything so much better
uh wow we got some
that's crazy
yeah that's me
that's hilarious
that's so cool
like to me this is this is just
fascinating I don't know really what I
could use it for other than profile
pictures and whatnot
but
or for little jokes and videos or
something
that's pretty sweet
so good
let's try doing abstract
um
Gustav what's that guy's name Gustav
Klimt
Goose stuff
Gustav Gustav
Gustav yes
there it is
by Gustav Klimt that's a
I don't know his work too much but
we got Alan Lee as well
let's see what that gives us
ah Ben I love it dude yeah you sniped it
for sure
um so one of my favorite games
of this year I think personally is my
game of the year is uh straight
and in stray oh boy okay here we go
let's definitely make sure
that would be the absolute worst
um this is crazy wow
jeez
let's try
um Alan Lee
who is the guy who did a lot of the
a lot of the concept design work for
Lord of the Rings but he's a very very
famous
famous artist
so anyway I was thinking about stray in
stray this game where you walk around in
abandoned city as a cat
um there is like a
there are memories throughout the city
and you can they're like collectible
memories you have find find them all
throughout the game get the trophy that
kind of thing right but um
in one of them it said you come up you
come up on this like spray painted image
on the wall and it's just like picture
of like a robot person thing and it was
giving a backstory on the world and it
said
at first AI artist like AI art
replicated humans art right the art from
Humanity but then eventually the AI
like artist models started making their
own art and
there became this very famous wave of
like AI artists like robot a artificial
artists they weren't people they were
like the machines going off creating
these wonderful pieces of art
um and they became famous
that's crazy and this is kind of a
similar thing where it's like
the machine is making all this stuff and
you're just kind of guiding it in which
way to go it's it's really
it's scary but it's exciting at the same
time and I'm just trying to be on the
side of like
how can I use this for my art how can I
use this to inspire me to make cooler
stuff
but
yeah this is this is nuts
this is nuts let's try um
let's try a pixel art I mean let's say a
pixel
um
well I'll just say let's say uh
screenshot of me
as
a
um
Grand Theft Auto character
video game
PlayStation uh let's see the graphics
see what that does
foreign
so I trained my model
um this is actually something that Jan
had trained on his side if you watch the
stream we go through it all we go
through all of it
um we're just at the tail end at this
point
I'm just kind of doing some last little
things but
oh my goodness what
that's so crazy
that's too good
wow
that's so good
dang
okay let's try this let's try it let's
try um as a
golden eye
um
see as a
as a golden eye video game
character
is it gold964 is that the full name of
it
let's see what that looks like
this one yeah
that's crazy
hmm
ah okay yeah it's a little low poly
action there I like that
that's pretty good
that's awesome
dude this one made me look like a mouse
what is my leg that's definitely a VFX
RS react like image
on this couch oh my goodness
PlayStation one character
low poly
um
low res
olution
um no text
and let's see let's know extra limbs
let's see what that does
I think I'm gonna go after this guys
I gotta eat
thank you for your time everybody
um yeah hit me up with any questions on
Discord I'm on Discord if you guys got
questions I'll uh happy to answer
you can DM me
oh here we go
that's nuts
ah so good the foot's a little jacked up
there
that's the definitely the corridor
background
that wall
yes
all right guys I'll I'll leave you I'll
leave you with that thank you so much
for popping in for this entire stream uh
it'll be on online forever so go back
watch the craziness
um let me know what you can create it'll
be fun we had the mid-journey servers
added on the Discord
um or the mid-journey bot rather added
to our two the Discord server Linked In
the description below go have fun y'all
um let's see what we can do thank you so
much thank you for your time I'll catch
you guys uh two weeks later I got a
video coming out speed environments in
Unreal Engine how to recreate your
memories in a day's time all right y'all
peace out later bye
[Music]